e
just start
good morning today is Monday February
10th
2025 and this is the New Hampshire House
of Representatives Municipal and County
government committee I am representative
Diane power the committee has convened
today for public hearings followed by an
executive session this afternoon now
please make sure that your cell phones
are silenced and please join me in
reciting the Pledge of Allegiance led by
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
all so before we begin today as always I
have a few Morning Ann announcements so
the committee has convened here at 9:30
for public hearings on seven bills after
the public hearings scheduled for
10:35 the committee will break for lunch
and then public hearings will resume at
1M also an executive session has been
scheduled after our publicly noticed
hearings to begin around 2
p.m. however please note that it has
been noticed that executive sessions on
pending legislation may be held
throughout the day time permitting from
convened additionally in order for us to
stay on schedule today the chair will
allow for up to 5 minutes for Bill
introductions followed by questions and
answers and then up to three minutes
will be given for in-person public
testimony with additional time allowed
permits and that's based on the number
of pin cards that I get um the vice
chair will indicate that the time is
expired by holding up a pin card at
which time we would ask that you would
um succinctly um wrap up your testimony
if a speaker has written testimony
please indicate that and distribute it
to the committee um via representative
Walker at this time and we'll pass that
along also if a speaker has more
information that they wish to share with
the committee then please let us know
and then follow up with written
testimony sent to all committee members
by
email finally as a reminder to speakers
providing inperson
testimony um first off please State for
the record your name who you represent
and your position on the bill support
oppose or
neutral and when the clerk is ready um
at this time the chair will open the
public hearing on House Bill 547 FN
relative to County reimbursement of
funds and first up the chair would like
to recognize representative Pearson to
introduce the bill to us
today welcome representative Pearson and
good
morning good morning
colleagues for the record Representative
Steve Pearson Rockingham District 13
which encompasses the town of dairy I'd
like to thank you for the opportunity to
have a seat in the big chair here today
and have a very brief introduction on H
Bill 547 547 was filed at the request of
the
counties and it has to do with the
exciting and riveting world of medic
assistance
reimbursement I am not an expert in this
field at all uh we are fortunate that we
have Chuck Nickerson who from rocking
Camp County who is the treasurer of that
organization who can explain this to you
it thank you representative Pearson and
so we will defer questions to subject
matter experts wonderful thank correct
you next the chair would like to
recognize representative Edwards to
bill welcome to Municipal and County
government good
morning good morning uh thank you for
having me uh I'm representative Jess
Edwards and um I I work with um oh I'm
I'm from Rockingham District 31 that's
Auburn Chester candy and Deerfield um I
I work closely with Mr Nickerson often
uh in the Rockingham County delegation
I'm really glad that representative
Pearson stepped up and submitted this
bill on behalf of the counties um I I on
my pin card I didn't say I was either in
favor or opposed um I just wanted you
all to have a little bit of context and
the cont text to keep it short because
Mr Nickerson will dive into the
details is that the 11.2 million you see
in the bill is uh money that a a fair
person would argue the state owes the
counties uh the the issue in this budget
cycle though I want to tell you as the
chair of division three um we we have um
uh issues with coming up with enough
revenues to cover all the existing
expenses and this looks like a new
expense it looks like it because uh not
that it is uh but it wasn't recognized
in the agency budget process it's not
going to probably not be part of the
governor's budget uh the so the budget's
going to come to division three and if
this requirement is in there as is we
got to find the 11 million somewhere
which means we're going to have to given
the fact that the revenues will be
static we're going to have to find
replacement money okay so um so as
you're listening to this and thinking
about what you're going to do with this
bill I just want you to be aware that
there's some um secondary effects
that'll be pretty significant and I just
would ask you to be careful as you think
through it and that that's really my
testimony I don't have a recommendation
to do it or not I want to hear what this
committee thinks but I want you to be
thinking it in the context of uh the
financial situation going into a budget
cycle very tough one thank you
representative Edwards are you willing
to take questions yes ma'am questions
representative all right it's go go
ahead so um just to be clear you you
commented that the
these
monies that the state allegedly owes the
counties has not been budgeted for could
you could you explain that or is it just
yeah so in the prior years and Mr
Nickerson will tell you exactly how this
happened there was a double collection
on some money that was due to the county
and the federal portion came in as the
federal portion came in it was accounted
for um and so the the numbers are are
pretty good around this but um uh
instead of um uh advancing or or or or
pushing through pass through is the term
I'm looking for instead of passing
through the monies received for the Feds
that was meant for the counties it ended
up going into our rainy day fund so the
the cash is there it's in the rainy day
fund apparently um but as the agencies
and then I'm sure the governor I I hate
to say too much because she releases her
budget this week um I bet I'm betting
that this 11.2 million transfer from the
state to the counties is not in their
budget proposal and so because it won't
be in their budget proposal um it'll be
left to the finance committee if if you
all um have us pass this bill uh to to
find the money because it won't be
probably in the budget
So based on what you just
said was there some sort of a like a
budgeting or accounting o oversight or
error if you will I I don't want to um
uh describe why it's not in the budget
why the department didn't put it in the
budget I I I I if somebody's from the
Department they'd be in a better
position to answer that I I I just know
the Practical implication when this
arrives on the doorstep of Finance
is it's probably not going to be in the
budget and if we want to give them the
not give them if we want to pass through
the 11 million then we're going to have
to find 11 million and finding 11
million is a lot of
money understood but what I was pointing
towards is in the previous budget the
fact that it wasn't the money was
received from the federal government it
wasn't passed through to the counties
and instead it ended up in the rainy day
fund that that's what I was asking like
what happened there why well because our
budgets are done in advance and they're
two years and and so this became I think
uh from the budgeting perspective the
previous term new
money and it just wasn't accounted for
in the budget that is going to expire at
the end of June and so I'm talking about
going forward the new budget it's
probably not going to the the pass
through probably isn't in there either
I appreciate your explanation yeah no
I'm sorry I I I I assume too much
sometimes I see that um the
representative Gerard has a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question I I'm hearing you're saying
that the 11 Point whatever the amount is
is not in the budget the previous two
years there was a 9.4 million if I
recall uh correctly was that not
budgeted for or how was that accounted
for the last two years that was in the
Rus bills uh
previously we've budgeted money for the
County's share of the county cap and
we'll be doing that again this year but
I think this is this is incremental
money I don't I I'm going to I'm going
to ask Mr
Nickerson if the $9 million that the
representative is referring to was a
different source of funding than this
2225 million is
isn't
it why don't you note that and then when
when you're there in at the mic you
could um fill in thank I think it's I
think it's a different uh increment of
money thank you yeah further
questions seeing none thank you all
right thank you sorry to share finances
problems with you but I it's really
important that we hear what you
think at this time the chair recognized
is Miss Kate
pile at this time the chair recognizes
Nickerson good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning members of the committee my name
is uh Charles Nickerson I'm the finance
director of Rockham County I'm also the
treasur of the Hampshire Association
counties and that's the organization I'm
representing here with my
testimony um just to to go back um there
was a letter from the president of the
New Hampshire Association of counties
Kathy Stacy on that hopefully was passed
around to the members of the committee
and uh my testimony will be closely
following along with uh the statements
made in that letter um I just want to
back up that basically counties are per
current state law are responsible for
the non-federal share of Medicaid
assistance to the elderly and disabled
whether it's services in a long-term
care facility uh such as a nursing home
or services that the individuals
receiving in the community so times you
hear that as Home and Community Based
care or choices for Independents so
whether it might be VNA Services Brain
Injury Association Services even
transportation services so the counties
by law are supposed to be only
responsible for that non non Federal
share of those Medicaid services that
represented in state law as known as the
so-called County cap now the federal
portion of covering those Medicaid
services is cons is called the fmap the
federal medical assistance percentage
historically that had been a 5050 split
50% federal government 50 50% counties
now what happened was with early
legislation as a result of Public Health
Emergency during the early days of covid
that um that fmap percentage increased
from 50 to
56.2 So in theory in reality the
County's portion should have gone down
to
43.8 going from 50% down to 43.8 is not
just a 6.2% difference it's a
12.4%
reduction now now again the going back
to the county caps the county caps are
established through the budget process
as far as dollar amounts so I can see
easily how because of the budgetary
process the state could not account for
this increase in the fmap UPF front it
just can't and I could understand
legislatively that it'd be hard to get
these amounts into the budget as well
and so briefly touched upon the $9
million that was actually an incorrect
amount incorrect calc calculation that
was provided and it got dropped during
the budget process so even though it's
in statute if you go under the law it
was never truly enacted at all it got in
a way left off from the ultimate budget
that was passed now the real numbers are
actually quite a bit higher and I will
say that DHHS did work with the state to
make sure that the counties were made
whole for this increase in the fmap
basically starting from 71 of 21 forward
but that still left the first 18 months
of this increase in the fmap that
basically DHHS double collected for that
12.4% of claims from the counties
through payments of a county cap that
was not subsequently adjusted and also
collected you know collected the
56.2% instead of 50% from the federal
government and as a result over it might
seem improbable but when you're talk
about a county cap that can be 1201 130
million 12.4% is a big big difference
over 18 months and the HHS actually has
the actual number for that 18 months at
over 25 million not 22 and a half I
think if you take the credit that's been
years and so we're just asking for
basically in hindsight for the law to be
followed and for um only the Count's
being responsible for the non-federal
share and we are asking for the credit
over two years because this occurred
over two years and again we're
understandable about the the whole
budget process the legislative process
things thank you are there
questions representative Gerard thank
you madam chair and thank you Mr nickers
for taking my question um one question I
had was in paragraphs three and four it
always talked about six it was accounted
for for patients that were 65 and older
is there a reason why paragraphs 5 and
six do not reference being 65 and
older um because it is not so this is
also assistance for the disabled so it's
not necessarily that you're just it's
it's Bas as far well I think they're
rebranding themselves but um so it's
assistance the elderly and disabled so
it's not just necessarily the those that
are over 65 but is individuals that are
on Medicaid that are receiving services
in the community or in a nursing
facility thank
you further
questions representative majori thank
you madam chair women to thank you for
taking my question and being here to
testify if if this if this bill were to
pass and indeed the money is not
available are we obligated to find it or
could It Go unpaid and if so what would
happen well I I guess the the issue is
what the law of states the law of states
the counties are responsible for the
nonfederal
share so if if the state wants to comply
with the law then that's what this this
bill allows for that after the fact for
the state to be in compliance with the
law and again the actual amount is is a
bit higher but the request is not to
adjust what's in the proposed bill um as
far as impacts if it's not I mean
obviously it means you know already that
the counties have taken more of a uh
actual results hit that they should have
or the first 18 months and I again I
fully understand the state could not
accommodate you know because again
through the different processes that we
have budgetary and legislative and also
who knew how long the public health
emergency was going to last because
that's what this increase in the federal
medical assistance percentage was tied
to so I understand why it did not happen
upfront I understand why it didn't
happen a year or even two years after
you know this situation was occurring
But Here we are now and it's still not
rectified at least in the eyes of the
counties additional
questions seeing none thank you right
thank
you so that that is the final pink card
that we have for House Bill
547 so at this time I will ask is there
anyone present who wishes to speak on
the bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do
so okay seeing none the chair recognizes
sheets thank you madam chair on the uh
remote signin we had two in support and
five oppos
post and the paper sheets coming
somebody down that and should report
that
one ready yeah excellent there is no one
on the blue
sheet thank you and with that the public
okay
oh WR that
okay at this time the chair will open
the public hearing on House Bill
569 relative to the establishment of
districts the chair recognizes
representative Howard to introduce the
bill welcome to Municipal and County
government good morning good morning
thank you madam chair uh and thank you
honorable committee members thank you
for having me this morning uh HB 569 is
all about governmental efficiency in
establishing Communications districts uh
this would give counties the power to uh
enable themselves uh to create these
districts which if you aren't aware
Communications districts are basically
the banding together of
municipalities uh in order to create a
uh a more um compelling uh contract for
uh different uh Communications uh
providers and that means people who
would provide are internet
services uh so there a number of
economic advantages to establishing
districts uh at the size of a County due
to the economies of scale because there
needs to be enough subscribers in order
to make it economically viable it is
cheaper for everyone involved if there
are more municipalities because it
expands the potential scri subscriber
base uh there are of course costs
included in this but that would be taken
up by each individual County and the
individual subscribers that would choose
to buy into this uh it is something
where it this is only enabling
legislation so it doesn't actually uh
necessarily deal with any sort of uh
local Establishment Clause but in terms
of the economic opportunities uh if we
look at uh places like Chattanooga
Tennessee that have implemented similar
Broadband infrastructure they have seen
uh their EBP Network create $2.69
billion doar and brought in nearly
10,000 jobs to the city so that's a lot
of economic growth and we can see that
here in New Hampshire as
well so just for people who are unaware
last session this bill did C come
forward and there was a little bit of
debate as to whether or not counties
actually already had the power to do
this uh today I've actually brought some
uh a letter from the straford county
attorney talking about uh H RSA
53g and its ability to be used by County
uh Commissioners and currently under her
interpretation of the law we cannot
currently do that I can send that the
her email Emil around because I only
have the one copy uh that I did bring
today uh so I do apologize about that
but as for uh the current enabling
structure municipalities they have to
individually go to each select board and
say do you want to join it makes it
unbelievably difficult to get one of
these districts established it would be
a lot simpler and make a lot more sense
the economies of scale if the County
Commissioners could just invite the
towns in the county to come and say do
you want to join this and then allow
them the option to opt out with that
being said uh I think that I've covered
everything that this bill does and uh
you thank you questions for
representative
Elward thank you madam chairman and
thank you for uh testifying
today are there any counties that are
currently voluntarily
uh forming these districts so uh there
is already one grafting County but not
all of the communities in grafting
County have and that was part of the
reason last session that there was this
debate because uh the Grafton County uh
Communications District was established
by local communities within Grafton
County uh cooperating together not the
County Commissioners inviting everybody
to look into studying whether or not
this would be a good idea
further questions representative
Colby
would would this disallow certain
communities to continue with their
current benefits that's are in their
contracts no this this does not change
any current established districts it
only changes the establishment uh or uh
of how uh these districts could be
established so it only affect new
you additional
questions representative Gilman is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm going to follow up on
representative Colby's question if uh
three or more communities have
agreements with let's say comp Comcast
and are funding their uh local TV
through the
um fees charges
is um would joining a county
then disperse those funds amongst the
towns or are there still a contract with
each town I believe there would still be
a contract with each town and depending
on what that contract stated uh whether
there was an exclusivity Clause they
could opt out of the countywide district
uh so that would not necessarily
interfere with that secondly it would
actually probably reduce rates for
everybody if these municipalities
decided to join because when you have a
larger district with more subscribers
lower representative Gerard has a
question thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question I
know this is part of the previous bill
it talks about governing body of two or
more municipalities but then it says at
least two persons per municipality when
you start getting into a county you're
going to have a committee of 100 people
that are going to be required and it
also talks about may be reimbursed how
is that all going to take place and
don't you think that maybe a 100 person
committee might be a little difficult to
deal with as well yeah I I appreciate
the question uh yeah there was actually
a clause in the uh Bill last term that
actually reduced the number uh of uh
members from counties if the if it was
established to their County to only be
one member uh so that was removed
because obviously that would create two
different class
and we wanted to kind of avoid that um
if that's something that you feel would
be beneficial I would be more than happy
to bring that back in thank you
questions I I just had had a
clarification so to be clear this this
bill your amended language to to the RSA
is
enabling a a county to establish a
committee
it's a
committee known as of the communications
District planning committee so that's
the first step this is not this bill is
is not in
initially um establishing this
Communications District that's that
would be the goal down the road and yes
also if and when it came to establishing
a Communications District
um min municipalities that were not
interested in participating May opt out
so just to be clear this is about
establishing a committee to
explore the possibility the pluses
minuses of
um
creating a Communications District yes
ex exactly that's the first step you
look at creating a study committee you
look at all the pros and cons to whether
or not it would be a good idea uh and
then uh of course municipalities can opt
out at any point uh and choose whether
or not they want to uh stay with their
current contracts or move into uh
Communications District so uh I like you
said it is only enabling language and
does not change anything uh for
currently established districts uh so it
it will make it so that there will only
be a uh study committee formed first and
then they can look at whether or not
they want to actually form the full
District thank
you any additional questions seeing none
much next the chair recognizes Mr Brody
Des good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you to the committee for taking my
testimony my name is Brody Dees I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and I'm speaking in
opposition to house bill
569 um our biggest piece of opposition
is as general principle um legislation
like this should be opt in
municipalities and their governing body
should be determining whether or not
they opt into this planning process for
a Communications District planning
committee and I appreciate that the
chairwoman pointed out that this is a
planning committee so it's not the
establishment of the communications
District you'll notice in section four
of the bill it actually kind of
describes after bylaws or um what
um that there's a proposed District
agreement which often times takes the
form of bylaws that are created as I do
the planning process and then there is a
requirement for there to be a
presentation each municipality and then
actually the legislative bodies need to
approve whether or not the municipality
joins a Communications District but this
is for the communications District
planning committee and we don't think
that the county should be the
Commissioners um establishing these
planning committees and then requiring
each municipality have to opt out if
they don't want to join there are
already existing um uh Communications
districts that were born naturally from
the planning committees um one in Carol
County there's one in Grafton County so
there's two currently that are operating
um and they've been able to organize and
to do all of this without having the
County Commissioners mandate that the
municipalities decide whether or not to
join the municipalities have banded
together I do want to point out just as
a um another General as side is that
Hampshire Electric Co-op has been
building out its um its Broadband
infrastructure and so a lot of the
reasons why communities are creating
these um these communication districts
is because they want to procure grant
funding and they want to procure um uh
you know build you know um economies of
scale uh for building out uh Broadband
infrastructure so in some cases your
municipality probably doesn't want to
join because you're essentially waiting
over the next you know anywhere from 2
to 5 years for the nire Electric Co-op
to build out that infrastructure there
is some benefits for negotiating
contracts um however you know I won't I
don't know too too much about that but I
do know that there is benefits to that
so um again as general principle though
we don't think that the county should be
requiring the governing bodies to have
to take action on a Communications
District that instead it should be the
governing bodies naturally working
together and organically establishing
these planning uh districts and not
coming from the counties uh so with that
I'll answer any questions thank you Mr
Des
you and the final pink card that I have
for House Bill 569 is from Mr or
mcis yep you can give it to
you so good morning and welcome to
government good morning Madam chair and
members of the municipal County
government committee my name is George
mcgis I'm president of New Hampshire
County Commissioner's Council a position
I've held for the last 27 years or so uh
I I'm here in support of House Bill 6 56
9 which is simply an enabling act uh
that allows uh counties to create
commiss communication districts if they
so choose and it gets and eliminates
some of the ambiguity in the present
law now I can understand the the
concerns regarding the municipal
Association they assume that they don't
want the count is BAS basically telling
the communities what to do and I get
that however not all counties are the
same
and as an example in my County I have
three
cities those three cities often reach
out to the county and ask the county to
deal with problems that they have that
they can't do on their
own so it has just the opposite effect
so you have some counties that want some
areas of the state that want the
counties to
participate on problems that they have
uh the the latest W and straford county
is an example is dealing with a homeless
issue no municipality is capable of
dealing with homelessness on their
own uh and because we have three cities
that are within 10 miles of each other
uh they've asked the county to act on
their behalf to deal with a homeless
issue so
uh I think you ought to make this piece
of legislation in your wisdom as as as
flexible as possible uh enable the
counties to operate allow the
municipalities to op in or
out uh they can do that by contract and
by or
byou uh it would also help some of the
more rural sections of our state the
more rural counties to be able to work
uh
collaboratively uh for any type of
infrastructure that would be deemed in
their
interest uh and and the consumer's
interest and I think that's what the
sponsor of the legislation is trying
trying to uh achieve so with that I'll
answer any
questions thank you commissioner mcis
questions representative Gilman is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question if this
passes um how do you see the
organization of it happening um you know
a central body versus well each Town
talking to itself versus well I think
that it if if it was handled in in the
way it ought to be handled which is have
the County Commissioners extend if they
so choose uh an invitation to the
municipalities to have a planning
discussion regarding
Communications uh and I don't
particularly think it ought to be uh I
think that's just a good idea generally
speaking I just think it's good public
policy to have that happen uh it's not
using a heavy hand it's just enabling
every people to have to act in
cooperation with one
another sometimes you'll find that uh
many small towns have a parochial
attitude and they want to keep
everything to themselves uh which works
in in some cases but it doesn't work in
all cases for instance you don't want
every town running its own jail for a
varying number of reasons you don't want
their your own town to uh run its own
nursing home as an example first of all
it doesn't make economic sense uh and so
I see it as more of I think it more in a
positive light is is to have the County
Commissioners if they so choose set up
uh by invitation to the towns uh a
planning committee to
study uh whether or not it's in our
their interest generally speaking and
maybe out of that comes uh Cooperative
efforts between communities
and not necessarily the county maybe the
county won't be involved but it's it's a
way to get everyone talking to one
another and then uh they may may they
may come up with collaboratives on their
own uh similar to what we do with school
example representative J Gerard is
recognized thank you madam chair and
thank you commissioner for taking my
question from what I just heard what you
stated that you're actually not opposed
to what nhma it stated in his testimony
that you're okay with an optin or opt
out method so either work well for you
that's correct thank
you further
questions I have a couple okay so um on
line seven of of the bill I I would like
to um point out right
that this is with regards to a
Communications District
planning committee cor and then if you
look at section four of the bill is this
this is the correct understanding is
that the planning um committee would
would um be uh
initiated by the County however once
that study committee is complete and
there are uh municipalities within that
County that are interested in coming
together
it the step thereafter is as it is right
now it it's it's commun it's
municipalities forming this
Communications district is that correct
that's how I understand it that's
correct thank you any other questions
and if I make one other point to you to
your your point Madam chair is that is
that you may find as a result of that
planning that they want the county
involved in some form of
and they may want to contract with the
county to do it simply because it makes
sense from an economic perspective uh
that happens uh on a number on a number
of different things because counties are
are a little different even though we
have the same basic services that are
required by Statute some counties run
different Services uh at the request of
municipalities
so it could go either way you could then
you you could probably as a result of
your planning your Planning
Commission uh they may make a
recommendation where you have say five
five towns in a particular County that
want to work uh with in a Cooperative
effort and the county would be out of it
they would those five towns would get
together but to me it's just it all just
makes sense for everybody to try to get
together and and at least start the
initial planning process and and see how
it develops it wouldn't be any any
situation where the county would demand
anything of the towns or
cities thank you um further questions
seeing none thank you
commissioner so at this time I will ask
is there anyone present who wishes to
speak on this bill who has not yet had
the opportunity to do so um seeing none
the chair now recognizes representative
Gilman to report out the blue sheet
sheets on House Bill 569 thank you madam
chair in the remote signin we had four
in support four opposed and one neutral
and on the blue paper blue sheet we had
one in support and one
opposed thank you representative Gilman
and with that I will close the public
representative
Walker um would you mind int introducing
the bill while you're
up
you after you're done sorting out the
signage
at at this time the chair will open the
public hearing on House Bill 643 FN
Commissioners and we have with us this
morning our own representative Walker to
introduce the bill to the committee
thank you representative David Walker
straford 19 not Grafton but
straford uh this bill expands the number
of uh Grafton County Commissioners from
3 to five and provides that all such
Commissioners shall be elected to
two-year
terms thank thank
you I assume there will be no questions
good
okay so next the chair recognizes
representative
Terry Spar Spar
Spar good morning and welcome to
you uh thank you committee um I am from
the uh Grafton uh County and I just
wanted to share some observations on
this bill with you from my perspective
and uh from what I can tell there was no
uh needs analysis done uh by the author
of this bill uh what it does do has add
two more positions expanding big
government
unnecessarily costing the taxpayers of
my County $40,000 more in taxes every
year this is at a time when uh our real
estate taxes are already ridiculously
high and may even go higher with uh you
know what's happening with the budget
cuts at the state
level
Here the uh non partisan Association of
uh New Hampshire counties uh scoffed at
this bill uh and of the 26
Representatives that are in our County
not a single one has co-sponsored it uh
this bill serves from what I can tell no
legitimate purpose uh is a waste of
resources and a waste of time for the uh
committee and uh does not make sense uh
for the citizens of New Hampshire and uh
stronger any questions oh thank you
you next the chair recognizes M Kelly
man Mayan Monahan Monahan sorry
okay handwriting these days thank you
madam chair honorable members of the
committee for hearing me today my my
name is Kelly manahan I've served as the
Grafton County Register of Deeds for 14
years surviving eight general elections
and three nasty primaries Grafton county
is 5,000 square miles larger than the
state of New
Hampshire the uh two districts are a
good hour for those commissioner drives
to the county complex were very spread
out with a population of n roughly
94,000 uh as you know to win your seats
it requires the majority of a 3,000
votes um for commissioner level 30,000
for my level it's 990,000 constituents I
have to reach in that Geographic vast
Turf with very little media coverage
we're generally swamped with the general
election wave of partisan mailings and
you'll see historically the undervote at
the commissioner level is is very high
percentile because it's at the bottom of
the ballot and quite frankly many of our
citizens have no idea what the County
Commissioners do as you know the
delegation's responsible for the uh the
budget but the annual budget
what the Commissioners are responsible
for is policy decisions and those are
the invisible underlying decisions that
drive
costs when you have people that are are
not connected to the local community and
Workforce they make decisions based on
their political ideology and not in the
best interest of the county I do not
consider myself a politician I'm an
independent thinker and I've reached out
to my constituents who pay the
bills we are blessed with great tourism
scenery that's a high utilization of the
current use progam program Dartmouth
College Plymouth State University
Connecticut River me many lakes and
great utilization is set of the current
use system for hunting and farming and
two ski mountains and snowmobile trails
that's a wonderful draw but the actual
citizen working and living there is
being burdened with unbelievable
property tax
increases as the registered Deeds I've
seen a wave of people come into graphin
County through covid and it's not what
you think it is it's people Looking For
Freedom and peace and some space so I
really do believe that the the
demographics are shifting and with the
centralized College locations oh The
Forbidden college student vote that we
even discuss this specifically if
affects the commissioner level vote to
divide that up I think this is a good
idea I'm sorry there's not more support
for it because dividing up our towns to
their interests of their people just at
the county level would go a great way at
their voices being heard
and I have many more points I can say
but I'd like to wrap it up and just take
any questions you have thank you for
questions seeing none thank you all
much on the fiscal note if I
may uh you can divide that what they're
currently spending by five since they're
covering Five Towns instead of three so
that wouldn't be an increase other than
the mileage which should there should be
oversight on that mileage thank you
next the chair recognizes Miss headed
Hedberg good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County
government good morning and thank you
good morning Madam chair and honorable
Meers members of the committee thank you
for allowing me to speak today my name
is Katie wood Hedberg and I'm the
Grafton County Commissioner from
District 3 and I'm here today to speak
in opposition to this bill the bottom
line is that this bill does not benefit
the county nor the citizens it also
increases County spending by about
$40,000 per year when it goes into
effect this is money the county can ill
afford to put towards such an
unprecedented unnecessary change looking
at some specifics it proposes to
redistrict outside of the traditional
process which can be confusing to
voters the new districts appear to be
drawn by geographical size with no
attention to population these districts
are very disperate in population size um
ranging by rough estimates from only
about 7,000 citizens to over
30,000 on close reading of the bill
permont one of our towns is not even
included in a district Grafton County
like the majority of New Hampshire
counties has adopted a rotating
four-year term to assure some continuity
with the board this has worked quite
well and I disagree with a proposal to
return to two-year terms some
institutional knowledge is imperative
for efficient management of any
organization knowing the history of
County initiatives both what was
successful and what fell short of the
stated goal prevents repeating mistakes
this is not a partisan issue it's a
strategy for Effective and efficient
government again I oppose the bill and
attention so before I forget you you've
indicated that that you do have written
testimony yeah I have one copy okay I I
can get copies of that if you pass that
along at at the end and if you want to
questions representative Walker
currently Grafton has what's your terms
foure terms um we um the out of the
three Commissioners there's two two-year
terms and one four-year term and so um
in this past election I was in District
three and I ran for a two-year term
district one didn't run she was in the
middle of a four-year term and District
Two um ran for a four-year term so this
means that there's two um there'll be
two new people but one person will
continue for a 4-year term to per
provide some stability and continuity
thank you eight of the counties in um
New Hampshire have adopted um the this
the set of terms of a rotating four-year
term further
questions seeing none thank you thank
much next the chair
recognizes m is it Martha m m McLoy
McLoud okay thank you madam chair good
morning and welcome to Municipal and
County
government thank you madam chair members
of the committee Martha McLoud I live in
frankonia I'm a a county commissioner
for Grafton County as well I serve
District Two which is the northern
Grafton County districts um sort of
Littleton hav roll down to the uh area
of
uh Thorton about that far South Lincoln
Woodstock area so a lot of the White
Mountain Regional uh Forest region of
the county and actually um I'm here uh
to represent a New Hampshire Association
of counties as well which gave me a
letter so it's short I'll quickly um
read the high points um they are
expressing their opposition to House
Bill
643 and um the bill would increase the
number of of County Commissioners from 3
to five and redistrict the entire County
um it's unprecedented to do this and
they don't see a need to make the change
or we don't really um this would be
outside the normal uh traditional
redistricting process so create a bit of
confusion for Grafton County can you
hear me yeah okay sorry um in addition
it eliminates the rotating four-year
term that was adopted just recently so
as commissioner Hedberg mentioned um our
folks from the southern part are already
in a four-year term I was just elected
for a four-year term I had served a
two-year term before that and then the
Plymouth area would be moving to a
four-year term uh in two years uh we
joined seven other counties and doing
this and it is to ensure continuity to
the Board of Commissioners and is seeing
the benefits of this um addition to the
board so we uh the association would
urge the committee to vote this bill an
expedient to legislate uh if you have
additional questions I can certainly
answer county level um but uh Kate Horan
is available to answer any of uh New
Hampshire Association of counties
questions and I have her testimony here
and then I did want to mention as uh
commissioner Hedberg said that Pont is
missing from a district 2 one of my
communities or my towns uh that I
represent uh and then uh I don't have a
whole lot more to add so I don't want to
do uh do that for you but I did grew up
in Grafton County I live in the house I
grew up in in frankc conia I graduated
from Littleton High School um I know the
county quite well um we're a real
outdoor recreation County as well as a
agricultural County along the river so
participating in hiking skiing and in
the 4 group as a young person um and so
I really don't see that this necessary
to expand the number of um Commissioners
to five I'm not sure that it really is
necessary to do that particularly in the
way that they have it in this piece oops
sorry about that um and our frankly our
our County delegation has not asked for
doing this and I think you all know as
members of the county delegation you
have that oversight over the
commissioner's budget uh and so that's
it seems to work quite well for us as it
is so I would ask you to um uh expedient
to legislate a recommendation on this
piece of legislation and if you have any
questions thank you for your testimony
questions seeing none and you'll pass
around I pass around the New Hampshire
Association of counties and then I'll
sign in remotely and put some my remarks
into your um online okay and also if you
want um you had written test did you
have written testimony of your own I
don't I just have it from the uh New
Hampshire Association perfect thank you
Phillips good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair and
thank you members of the committee uh my
name is Paul Phillips I'm a um homeowner
in Plymouth I'm a business owner in
Littleton uh and I'm a voter and
taxpayer in Grafton County I'm here to
oppose HB
643 uh this bill is a solution looking
for a non-existent problem the voters in
Grafton County haven't asked for and
don't need any Midstream redistricting
and we certainly we certainly don't need
to increase the number of County
Commissioners and districts from three
to five uh these unnecessary changes
will put an additional $40,000 per year
on Grafton County
taxpayers uh currently the Grafton
County Commissioners serve two-year
terms with one commissioner each cycle
serving a four-year term on a rotating
basis this system has provided stability
and continuity for County Commissioners
uh for a County Commission that has seen
regular turnover of its members uh HB
643 would do away with this local
solution and replace it with a conquered
solution strict uniformity in the
two-year terms but adding more districts
more Commissioners and more costs to
County government if the drafters of
this Bill had any interest in what the
voters of Grafton County actually wanted
they would put these question questions
on every town meeting warrant in Grafton
County and let the people decide if they
support these changes instead this bill
would impose a set of confusing and
unnecessary election changes on Grafton
County halfway through a 10-year
redistricting cycle uh solely to serve
political goals and not to serve the
people of Grafton County the proposed
new districts have no basis in
population numbers or Community cohesion
fully onethird of Grafton County's
population would be inexplicably
shoehorn into one of the five new
election districts this is not a
redistricting plan based on fairness but
only on political manipulation the
clearest evidence that the drafters uh
offer this proposal without concern for
the voters and communities of Grafton
county is that the new election
districts completely omit the town of
permont that one glaring glaring error
alone should be enough to kill this bill
and some I oppose HB 643 and I urge you
all to vote against it
thank you thank you Mr Phillips
questions for Mr
Phillips seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes
commissioner
chairman again members of the committee
George mcgis uh president of the
Hampshire County Commissioners Council
uh I appearent I I appear today before
you in opposition to this bill I want to
mention a couple of things to you folks
and then I'm going to sit
down uh I served on this committee
almost 50 years ago I was a member of
the minan County government
committee back then when we had changes
to be made to
County government in terms of the County
Commissioners it was always a decision
by the county delegation the delegation
would
meet and uh and look through things like
creating districts and four-year terms
and all these things and the delegation
then would would sponsor a bill uh to
change the way things are done in their
County and that was always
recognized uh by the
legislature and I can name you I've been
a county commissioner now for 21 terms I
can name you dozens and dozens of
instances where particular counties
wanted to do a certain thing in their
County uh but it was the county
delegation that made that decision
collectively in recent years we're
seeing these these bills that are that
are politically
motivated uh that didn't get the proper
political airing in the best term of the
word by the county delegation and this
is the case with what happened in
Grafton this particular bill it seems to
me that the delegation if we want to do
if history is any teacher and usually
history is a very good
teacher that the delegation should meet
on a on a proposal like this and air it
out themselves and then make a
determination as to how they wish to
govern their particular
County have legislation like this crop
up every these things have cropped up
over the years many many times uh they
usually don't gain any traction uh for
that very reason so I wanted to bring
that to your attention because that's
how we used to do it 50 years ago when I
was here and uh I didn't think it was a
bad practice uh and I think that
practice should continue thank you madam
chair thank you commissioner mlar
questions representative Walker is
recognized for a question yes
um how many uh does most counties in the
state of New Hampshire have three
Commissioners how many have more than
three nobody has more than three okay
they all have three that's what I
figured and that that was decided in
1856 uh when Commissioners positions
were created by
Statute uh they did
that those folks back then did it Bas
Bas basing it
on a Selectmen type of government that
they had in towns having three Selectmen
in most towns uh they decided that not
to have one commissioner uh
there was arguments as to having the
executive
counselor uh elect a number of executive
councils have that executive counsel act
as the commissioner for each County they
had multiple debates about this for many
many years but anyway they ended up they
ended up uh creating three Commissioners
similar to what they have in Towns at
the time now some towns have changed now
we have town councils and things like
that it's all evolved but initially you
didn't have that uh because because of
New Hampshire's distrust of
power um any the executive granch that's
why we have one of the weakest governors
in the country with with an executive
counsel who act as a check on the
governor uh same thing with County
government nothing can happen unless you
get two Commissioners to agree to it and
it's all because of our distrust of
government thank you for that
interesting history I appreciate it
further
questions representative Gilman has a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question uh I have
this committee has seen several bills
where different counties want want to be
treated differently and my question to
you is will you work with me over the
summer to see if we can straighten some
of them
up yeah I would be more than happy to do
that
uh I I I hate to say this but I'm going
to say it because it's the
truth at the end of this term I'll have
been in public office 50 years
years every one of these bills that I
have seen over that course of
time were mostly political
vendettas matter of fact 95% of them
were political
vendettas and we used to pride ourselves
and recognize that as as such years
ago in recent years we weaponized the
system against
people which I think is is doesn't serve
our the population
well uh as a and I'm a a member of the
old school Democratic party which just
basically doesn't exist anymore I'm a ro
Rosevelt and Truman Democrat my family's
been in public office in in the city of
Dover I'm a former mayor of the two-term
mayor of the city of Dober I didn't run
again because I gave it up for Lent
but but most of these types of
legislation over the course of time were
political vendettas some of them
survived the review of the county
delegation and it was and and and was
put into
law then so I don't mind working with
you or with this committee on any of
these things I just bring some kind of
historical perspective to it because
there's a lot of new members here third
of you turn over every every two years
that's just that's not me talking that's
just reality so you you have there's not
a lot of institutional knowledge left
here anymore and so we're we're forced
into these into our into our own little
our party systems which years ago
although that was the case after the
elections that was all put aside and we
did what was best interest of the people
in the end the weaponization that we
have today does not serve us well and
I'm just saying that for what it's
worth thank you further questions seeing
none thank you thank you so the last
pink card that I have is for
representative
Horgan good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County
government thank you it's good to be
here so I'm resident Timothy Horgan from
straford County District 10 which of
course is in straford County the town of
Durham and um hope I don't seem too
presumptuous for someone from straford
County speaking about a bill from
Grafton County although commissioner
mcis just spoke very eloquently and
actually one of the two sponsors is from
straford County and unlike I don't know
if she's ever lived in Grafton County
but I actually lived in Grafton County
for for 10 years lived in Orford and
then in um hover and then in in Lebanon
and I was even the Lebanon City chair
for two two years so I've got a little
bit of standing to talk about it so I
think apparently there's no local
interest in it so nobody's you know this
is something the sponsors came up on
their own and um so it's obvious there's
no support for it for that's one reason
probably not to move forward with the
bill and um there's and there's U also
the fact that they to town out the town
of permont the lovely town of permont
just north of Orford a place I know very
well so I'm like uh they deserve to be
in a county they deserve a county
commissioner too so um I I really don't
that's that's kind of an appalling
mistake actually and I'm um you know the
uh you know I'm surprised that that fell
through the cracks I'm surprised the
sponsors didn't notice it I'm surprised
the drafting attorney didn't notice it
I'm surprised the sponsors didn't turn
out the draft CF in and I'm also like
surprised that the leadership in the
caucus that the sponsors belong to never
noticed it so how how that happened
that's uh and we've had some errors like
that including uh one which I'll be
dealing with dealing with later and I'm
just uh amazed so I'm just amazed that
that could have happened so as somebody
I haven't been in office as long as
represent as commissioner mcis although
he's we're close to the same age I've
only been there 17 years but still like
I've been here long enough been in
office long enough to be kind of
personally embarrassed that such a
blatant error could have fall into the
practice so that alone is probably that
that alone kind of annoys me so that's
one of the reasons I S just sit down and
like take up two minutes of your your
time to uh say that I oppose the bill so
and if You' do want to expand the change
the Grafton County Commission um that
should be first of all that should
probably be done you know you know after
the next desial census in 2030 it should
be done with some you know local
discussion with some support from the
delegation and actually
ironically this particular county is
easier to divide into three parts than
any of the others because uh the
population is kind of most of the
population is down in one corner of the
county where Lebanon and Handover and
Enfield are and then there's uh where
Plymouth is is another population Center
and then up by uh then up in uh
Woodsville where the county seat is
another population Center so actually
it's fairly easy to like draw three
districts centered on those three
populations um you know though it's very
easy actually to divide into three
districts based on those three
population centers so I would and also
it's it's a small County so the district
would be pretty small so I would proably
small population in ter of counties so
like uh You' be drawing very small
districts so it's probably easier to
have three districts that's probably of
all the counties that's the one that
probably like needs a five a larger
County Commissioner District less than
any others so I would just say uh itl
this belill and it's reason enough that
they left the town out I as I said I
can't believe that happened like what
you know what the heck so anyway that
that's my testimony
so thank you representative Horgan
questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
thanks so that was the last pink card so
I will ask is there anybody present who
wishes to speak on the bill who has not
yet had the opportunity to do so seeing
none the chair recognizes representative
Gilman to report out the blue sheets
thank you madam chair um on the blue
sheet there was one in
support support uh but they ended up
speaking to us anyway um and on the
remote sign in there's zero in support
and 72
opposed thank you and with that I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
just
okay yeah representative page do do you
have a pink card oh it's coming from the
at this time the chair will open the
public hearing on House Bill 544 local
relative to an optional local public
safety assessment on certain room
occupancies
okay so the chair recognizes
representative Paige to introduce the
bill to us this morning welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning thank you madam chair thank you
to everyone for having me and I hope
that everyone enjoyed the amazing snow
we had yesterday um up in the valley it
was my son's uh 10th birthday party so
we spent the whole day out in the snow
having snowball fights having a great
time having s'mores that on bonfire and
it was a great time
um I hope all of you come up for the
snow to the Mount Washington Valley it's
a beautiful place to come uh all four
seasons we love having visitors I don't
know if folks saw but earlier this
season USA Today uh said that Conway is
America's best ski town and of course
those of us who live there know that
already but it was still a great honor
and it was exciting to see that
recognized and the next time you're up
in the Mount Washington Valley I hope
that you will enjoy it uh we love having
you I hope you'll also take a moment to
pause and think about what it takes to
run a town like
Conway and the way I think of it is we
kind of those of us who live in the
Mount Washington Valley it's like we
live simultaneously in two parallel
universes there's sort of one universe
in which we live uh you know on a weak
day night in April or a cold uh day in
November after the leaves are all gone
but before the snow comes where we live
in a really sleepy quain rural town it's
the town my mom grew up in it's the town
my granddad grew up in and it's a tiny
tiny Place tight-knit
community and then we live
simultaneously in this other
Universe which is pretty much any day in
the summer any holiday weekend uh a
powder day like we had
yesterday and that is a busy rockus
town the trouble
is that our population of about 10,000
people 10,000 locals
balloons at these different times of the
year so at any given point you know in
the summer we may be a town of 40,000
people instead of a town of 10,000
people and that poses huge
challenges for local people because it's
local people who are bearing all the
costs of that 40,000 Town 40,000 person
town that we sustain intermittently
what that means is everything is super
sized in Conway right so we have a
police force that is at least twice the
size of what you would expect in a town
of 10,000 but it's still those same
10,000 locals who are sustaining that we
have Wastewater infrastructure that is
built to accommodate those 40,000
people so this is a a big problem and if
you talk to constit my constituents in
my town this is the least partisan issue
you can
imagine everybody in town is on the same
page in this on this Democrat Republican
independent what we are
seeking are
tools we love our
visitors we love being this this
beautiful place uh that people come to
you know as my as my aunts says whenever
we're kind of like dealing with traffic
or any of these other annoying issues
that come from tourists being in town
she says how lucky are we that we get to
live in the place that everybody else
wants to come and I do feel that way I
feel that way I love where we
live but what all my constituents want
from the state from us here are better
tools to deal with the fact that these
this transient population in our
communities is such a major driver of
costs for the town we lack tools to
capture Municipal revenue from this
visitation to defay the costs that they
issue so this bill proposes one tool and
my my ask to everyone here with complete
humility is if you hate this
solution tell us what other solution
might work for you because the people in
my
town are frustrated they're frustrated
that they are bearing the costs of this
tourism which we all benefit from across
the state right all this money is you
know from rooms and meals is flowing
into our state budget it's helping us
pay for the things we all need it's
being dispersed out to other
municipalities so the folks in my town
are clamoring for for better tools that
will help us toay these costs that we
are bearing for
everyone I think we're flexible on the
solutions but in action for my
constituents is a
do the goal of this bill in essence is
to create a user fee for the municipal
services that our visitors often take
for granted right that police force that
oversized police force that oversized
Wastewater infrastructure all these
costs that we're bearing from
accommodating all of those visitors it
is a local option this is strictly local
option it would require approval of the
legislative body and all the revenues
collected would be held in a fund and
limited to the purposes contemplated by
this bill it's not a free frall it's not
just the money comes in and you can
spend it however you want it is intended
to be spent on defraying the costs that
this visitation
creates what this bill would do it was
it would allow the
municipality to create an occupancy fee
of up to $2 per
night that the municipality would then
hold and that those funds could be used
to defay those costs we also recognize
that there are some Associated costs to
the operators in this bill we have said
that just like with the meals and rooms
tax they are allowed to retain 3% of the
money they collect to help them to defay
their own
costs um so with that I will turn it
support questions representative
Gerard thank you madam CH thank you
representative for taking my questions
um I guess I I have a couple questions
hopefully I can do a followup in a
moment how do the overnight stays burden
the community I guess is my first
question how do overnight stays burden
the community is that the
question the transient traffic in the
community is the burden right so we have
you know if we have a town of 10,000
people and suddenly we have 40,000
people in the town we have all the
challenges of a town of 40,000 right so
while our local population has not grown
and our tax base has not grown we have
to have the police force that is able to
deal with that larger population and the
disruptions caused by that that larger
population similarly Wastewater is
another example our roads are another
example that we are dealing with a
tremendous amount um a visitation and
that that brings costs to the
municipality
followup
yes based upon your comments I'm looking
at lines 14 through 16 where you talk
about this money wouldn't go to the
general fund if we're actually trying to
offset the costs of services why
fund says such funds shall be used to
augment funding of the cost of Municipal
service associated with increase in
tourism trans any funds received shall
not be deemed part of the general fund
Community
Surplus um I think I follow your
question I think our goal here was to to
en our goal in this language was to
ensure and I think this was meant to
some degree as a reassurance to folks
that this money wouldn't just go toward
anything under the sun right that we
would try to ensure that these were
tailored to specific areas of the
municip municipal budget that were
impacted by that transient
you further questions the chair
recognizes representative
Colby thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um I'll keep it
1724 um two
and I think that's it uh adding the uh
Town
Council absolutely y okay thank
frock thank you madam chair thank you
representative for your presentation
I've been caught up in Conway traffic uh
numerous times I I appreciate your
dilemma uh I have two questions Maybe
one um firstly do you have an estimate
of how much revenue would be realized
through a local option rooms tax not to
exceed
$2 and does
that is that a $2 per room or per person
per
night thank you uh that is a great uh
question I don't have a current estimate
on that I know that our town manager was
hoping to be here uh and he would
probably be better able to comment on
that he did not make it I would be happy
to have him follow up with you on the
question regarding um the um
estimate I would say at this point it is
strict it would strictly be an estimate
right we I think we probably won't have
a a a great figure until it's actually
been collected right um and in terms of
um the
occupancy um my that's a good question
my assumption and my intention would was
that it would be per room but I will
double check on that and make sure that
that is the
case uh
followup yes uh would this tax also
occupancies it does include room
facilitators
correct further
questions representative majority thank
you madam chairwoman and thank you so
much for for taking my question I I have
long been in support of this kind of
idea being on the Sea Coast and and
experiencing similar things and I can't
believe I'm asking this question I must
have asked it before we must have
addressed it but have you contacted Dr
about the accounting for this is this a
do to do from kind of situation or you
know how does the money get transferred
and when or is that just part of what
the community would
establish the intent of the bill is for
municipality representative Gilman is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
um uh in your town are the water and
sewer Services uh Enterprise funds being
taxes that's a great question I'll have
to get back to you okay thank
you representative grund is
recognized great thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question so
following up
on for earlier question when towns
cities do their budgets they budget for
Revenue as well
so you would probably do an estimate
budget of the $2 you'd probably have an
idea the first year would be hard I'm
sure but you'd have you just put it into
a revenue line I don't know do you think
there's really a need to offset into a
special Revenue fund because it's going
to be dispersed of different utilities
different safety groups this and that
that it wouldn't it just be part of
Revenue so I think you're getting at the
same question that representative Gerard
asked um I
will I I don't object to the direction
in which you're headed with that
question however I will say that I have
received push back from those who have
concern that not handling it in this
manner would mean that the that the
funds could be used for unrel purposes
unrelated to those intended by the bill
so it was framed in this way to try to
address those concerns I I understand
what you're saying um but I think we
framed it this way to try to assuage
raised yes all right so a quick followup
so when we budget our expenses you're
budgeting for that 40,000 people not the
10,000 people so the revenue is there to
offset the expenses so I just go back to
it's going to be dispersed to so many
different groups this seems like a
complicated way to back the revenue
heard and
understood further questions the chair
recognizes representative lward thank
you madam
chairman thank you for taking my
question um I started doing research in
one town regarding short-term rentals
and whether or not they were registered
with Dr offer rooms and meals tax and
three out of
seven were
um research for enforcement purposes the
rooms and meals tax
registrations so you're raising a really
important question um and one that I
think is deserving of the legislator's
intention
attention the answer to your question
about Conway is yes um we have Town
staff who have in a very ineff manner
frankly um you know on the local
taxpayers dime done that work of going
onto these various platforms and
scraping that data and you know
determining how many of these rentals
are on the market those short-term
rentals I will say that that is a
very in my mind that is a very
inefficient way to do that work there
should be a way that a much more
efficient way to handle that and perhaps
at the state level but to answer your
question directly Conway is deciding to
do
that representative frock is recognized
for a question thank you madam
chair um another question have you done
any comparative analysis
between instituting a flat up to $2 per
room uh fee or tax versus any other sort
of local tax such as a
local uh say another percent on the
rooms and meals tax or perhaps
instituting I know this is New Hampshire
and it's not right but perhaps a one or
tax well I'll Echo your comment about
the last part about a sales tax I don't
think that's on the table ever
um
inter go for it you go for it um I'm
going to stay over here on that one um
in terms of meals and rooms I think that
is an that is an alternate path um I
will I will
say as my son would say the math the
math isn't mathing you know when I think
about trying to put put forward some
sort of rejiggering of our meals and
rooms formula to deliver more for
example not proposing this but for
example to deliver more of the revenue
to the towns that are contributing the
most what that suddenly starts is a war
between people in different
municipalities right where okay my town
may get more but that means your town
gets less and then when I think about
trying to move that through the
legislature whether or not I think it's
fairer I can't get you know Manchester's
not going to get on board Nash was going
to get on not going to get on board and
we I just don't see that as a realistic
path politically that we'll get it done
that way
personally um if this committee you know
back to my initial plea of if this
option doesn't work for you all help me
find an option that does um you know if
that's if this committee is on board
with that path let's talk but I think
this to me represents the most realistic
solution to the problem that towns like
mine
face further questions represent of
Colby is
recognized thank you R Madam chair thank
you for taking my question um I would be
happy to work with you on this um my
question was there there is um there's
an exception for municipalities for
rooms and meals tax um I think about
people who receive local assistance uh
from municipalities to stay in a hotel
right um would uh municipalities be
exempt and from from paying this $2
robbing Peter to PayPal yes that's the
intent there is a 30-day like typic
typically you're looking at like
emergency housing assistance is the kind
of thing I'm I'm assuming you're talking
about yeah um so there is a uh it only
it it would not apply for folks who are
for 30 days or longer in a motel for
example and we have a lot of that I
don't in in Carrol County we have we're
the only County that has no homeless
shelter and no transitional housing um
so that is how we handle that and we
tried to craft this to accommodate that
we I'm also open to additional language
there to reinforce that thank you
additional
questions seeing seeing none thank you
thank
you next the chair recognizes
representative
Woodcock thank you madam chair um I can
assure you when we start it will not be
as eloquent as the pray speaker um I
will give you a little uh answer another
question you brought up before the short
ter rental in the hotels and and try to
get a picture for
you when David was talking about the
consistent upper when people say to me
when the first thing I see coming out of
the car next door is two 30 packs of Bud
Light I know it's going to be a tough
weekend for me because they are sdrs
that are in in multiple areas formerly
residential areas in
town uh and if you driven through the
strip with remaining of the strip in
North Conway if you could get through
one of BU today uh there are multiple
hotels and and and those can Le on as um
concerning some of the Str strs that you
were talking about but the question
becomes where ises this money going why
it's because we have the additional
shortterm folks there hotels a little
more policing significantly by their
security staffs than other people in
town that creates more calls for our
police more calls for our fire more
calls for our EMS service these services
that are paid out of local taxes local
representatives and get no reimbursement
for there's nothing coming back to the
town for the extra calls so when Dave
was talking about going a double police
force to size 20,000 or 10,000 people
and now 30 or 40 that's where the some
of their cost comes from and that's why
the separate count was to go back for
police Fire EMS and Wastewater we are a
small town last year we sat here at
David N and the mayors of uh Manchester
conquer Portsmouth Hamin they were all
here because this is enabling
legislation this is not for the state
this is if they particular town or city
wants it a few folks allow it and the
house downstairs allows it and it goes
through the process um because it gives
them another tool as as they indicated
so that's one of that's the big concern
with this particular piece of legis
ation is it is a tool for those
particular locals that have it's not for
every city in town there's a lot of
cities in towns in New Hampshire uh that
don't have a hotel who don't have these
problems and don't have the extra cost
of
services so we have a hard time keeping
up with that uh cost in our town because
it goes back to the 10,000 people you're
all talking about taxes New Hampshire
residential tax and the after your
assessment the bill comes in I'm sure
your town are different than ours
they're all screaming the taxes are up
but they are up but these are
artificially uh increased because of the
costs that aren't related to what locals
get out of it and that's the whole
purpose of this of this piece um and i'
go back to the fact that it is enabling
and that we're just trying to uh help
those three services please fire us last
year we had five fire departments in
town three volunteer two with two
employees two with one this year we have
two remaining volunteers unlike David
they're like me they're getting too old
and there's nobody left in the fire
departments so that this just the cost
of increased fire department inre
increased Staffing uh in the two we have
ref the EMS serve the same
way and I guess I guess I would close
with a picture and the picture is my
hotel bill when I go someplace typically
people travel for a couple reasons
unfortunately for death or illness and
all the rest the discretionary money and
when you get your hotel buillt and I'm
sure I'm at the lower end because I stay
at the lower the hotel bill uh versus
the con has hotels that go from $200 to
$500 a night right I'm sure some of the
towns you
have and you get the your $250 Bill and
you get this tax that tax and you look
down the bottom I'm taking it now Tak it
to Disneyland right you get a hotel bill
that says $200 a night in a local tax
state tax county tax safy assessment $2
D you aren't thinking about those $2
you're paying $ 250 $500 your hotel bill
the last thing you're thinking about is
a $2 safety assessment it's nothing to
you it's not going to impact tourism by
any means it's not going to impact our
bnbs it's not going to impact anything
so this this enabling legislation is
actually putting an additional safety
fee for safety for the people coming to
our town that's causing additional costs
for our town and I would be happy to
take any U questions that you may have
and I'm sure I get stuck call
David thank you representative Woodcock
questions for the representative seeing
none oh I'm sorry represent Vice
chairman McDonald's is recognized thank
you nice to see you representative
Woodcock why can't you as a town just
charge the hotel that fee and they don't
pass it on to the
consumer you mean the nightly occupant
fee yeah I just don't want I don't I
don't like to just I don't want to like
a bill where it says uh $200 here in
rooms in tax $50 and then this whatever
you want to call this particular fee why
can't you as a community automatically
just charge the hotel for uh say 100
nights at whatever fee you want to
charge him at $200 without passing it on
to the
consumer repr MCD that's a an
interesting question we hadn't thought
of that um candly because you roll it
into the hotels which are easier
obviously to dialogue with in terms of
of reconciliation but the the shter
rentals uh in our town are also an
additional I would say more problemsome
than the hotels so it's just trying to
get back because it's not going to
impact uh the the business and the
operator of the hotel uh so I think it
becomes more discriminatory when you do
that when you say you're just going to
charge the hotels or on on every night
um it's also easy to doing nightly
occupancy and as the bill shows anything
over 30 it's not going to hit any body
any Apartments if you rent the apartment
for a month it's not going to impact
that it's just it's just the people who
are there and transient tourists using
those costs so we hadn't looked at that
be honest represent do because we
thought it at least time two years ago
was more um discriminatory trying to
identify a particular entity and then
charge it for cost that may not
be thank you but thank you further
questions representative majori thank
you madam chair W and thank you
representative taking my quick question
how many
fulltime and
volunteer uh firefighters do you have
firefighters paramedics the whole
range volunteer and
full-time we have three I think three
and two we have maybe the maximum of
seven I'm going to say between the two
new stations because they just came
together maybe seven full-time um and
volunteer every time you ring the bell
who can get out of work so I have no
idea if they're down here if it down
here when it goes off we just have a
nice Foundation left when you get there
yeah additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very much M
Dees thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you to the committee uh for the
record my name is Brody Dees I represent
the Hampshire Municipal Hampshire
Municipal Association and we strongly
support house bill um 54 4 I'll be very
brief with my testimony this would allow
um would allow the legislative bodies
and municipalities to adopt a local two
up to a local $2 per occupancy fee uh
for folks who stay overnight at hotels
um this is a very modest fee um by
looking for public support you're
essentially asking your property
taxpayers for a new form of relief
Hampshire has a long history of making
sure that tourists who utilize our
communities and our spaces um that
they're helping offset the cost to the
state municipalities this was done you
know for at least 50 years now with the
meals and rooms tax um the goal of this
bill would be for that $2 up to that $2
modest fee it could be less than that it
could be a percentage but no more than
$2 um would offset the disproportionate
costs some municipalities bear to drive
this rooms of meals tax revenue and to
drive our tourism economy um there are
some of our larger cities or some of our
more tourism towns like wolf bro Conway
or others really do a lot to build their
infrastructure to make sure that there's
the proper
um that there's the proper
infrastructure there that exists to
ensure that hotels and higher density
development can be there and um and to
take care of their different public
spaces beaches and other recreating
areas um so that our tourism economy Can
Survive and Thrive and some
municipalities would like to be able to
have the right to raise this $2 fee to
help offset those costs specifically in
this case um to whatever the public body
would decide this money would go towards
whether it's strictly Public Safety
upkeep of some of the different
infrastructure costs um whatever kind of
Tourism related expenses there may be um
this bill supports local property
taxpayers so then that burden doesn't
just fall into them municipalities have
only one way of raising revenue um
that's through either different fees the
state permits or property taxes and the
majority of um the different support
that municipalities provide in the
different infrastructure they provide to
support a tourism industry fall on the
backs of property taxpayers so this bill
would be a creative solution or some
form of it I've heard some interesting
and good ideas to help those
municipalities though figure out a way
to make sure that the burden of
supporting the tourism industry isn't
just on the property taxpayers that some
of that burden can be shared by those
who are visiting recreating and
utilizing the services who aren't
full-time residents of the state but
visitors and who are probably quite
happy considering they're racking up
bills on other things to pay that
additional $2 a night to help
keep our uh our tourism industry
sustainable and our our funding stream
sustainable too for the property
taxpayers and with that I'll take any
questions thank you Mr Dees
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so the last pin card that I have is
milbrand good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning thank you madam chair and thank
you committee members my name is Heidi
milbrand I own and operate Pleasant viw
bed and breakfast in Bristol New
Hampshire I've been the in wench up
there for over 21 years I am also the
president of the Lakes Region bed and
breakfast Association I'm the past
president of the New Hampshire bed and
breakfast Association and I am the
current Vice chair of lodging on the New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association I here to speak against HB
and I must start off by saying here we
go again I need someone to explain to me
why they feel the need to single out
lodging just lodging for this ridiculous
tax and that's what it is a tax which
down the road is going to encourage more
worthless legislation for unne for more
unnecessary taxes this so-called fee is
very
discriminatory and I love that word
discriminatory in today's world it
states in your proposed bill that the
fund shall be used used to augment
funding for the cost of Municipal
Services associated with the increase in
tourism and transient taxes do people
just magically show up at my bed and
breakfast and not go anywhere or do
anything why not add this fee to
restaurant bills at the gas pumps at the
tolls at the grocery store and
entertainment facilities tourism is a
major part of the New Hampshire economy
why is lodging being singled out and
called a burden to Municipal budgets
I'll answer that for you lodging
facilities are not a particular burden
they're just an easy target to tax my
business sits in the beautiful new
Newfound Lake Region and we rely heavily
on tourists legitimate lodging establ
establishments already collect 8 and a
half% M&R and the M&R has already lost
its credibility what was once used to
promote tourism in the state now goes
into the general fund line in my town to
be used for whatever and I'm just going
to digress a second here I was sitting
back there
and uh even in the previous two bills
that we heard people were complaining of
their their increase in taxes personally
my taxes just went up over $3,000 this
year over
$3,000 in
taxes and I looked at Conway's M&R what
they're getting for their taxes and from
M&R they're getting over $900,000 this
year that can that's going to pay a lot
of cops for some public safety out there
and I'm sure this happens with other
other cities and towns when they receive
their fair share of the M&R and now
somewhat more adding another fee to my
guest is going to deter them from stain
and reduce my business when I travel
nothing frustrates me more than seeing
my bill from a lodging facility that
includes a city tax occupancy tax a
state tax and an airport tax if I happen
to stay near one as legitimate lodging
businesses we're already undermined by
Airbnb VRBO and other online booking
companies as well as real estate rental
companies who do and can work outside
the state Rags are towns going to be
required are able to collect the $2 per
room per night from these online
companies and if you look at the RSA
which I did this morning at 7:30 uh
airbnbs vrbos are not covered in the RSA
and according to the stats they rent a
lot of rooms they're not just Mrs Smith
renting an extra room in her house
they're major International companies
Bristol has one one legitimate lodging
me and no other legitimate lodging
operations and I am as our my fellow B&B
and inke Keepers very transparent in our
operations because companies like Airbnb
don't have to compete on a Level Playing
Field we're losing local business I
can't see how my seven room bed and
breakfast is going to make enough to
fund our Town's ability to aument
funding for the cost of Municipal
Services associated with the increase in
tourism and transient traffic and again
I'm going to digress when he said when I
can't see his name it's it's got a glare
on it they're going to charge just bill
us an estimated amount of money Bill me
directly for how many rooms I have
seriously I see that these revenues
collected shall be deposited in a
capital reserve fund tourism support
fund revolving fund or other special
Revenue fund and as may be authorized
and the requirement for the use of these
funds is so loose that ways will be
devised to use them anyway so you want
to tax one business one business for the
benefit of a Town's bottom line and how
is this tax going to be enforced does it
give the state or even my town the right
to audit me to make sure I'm giving my
town the $2 a room Big Brother's truly
watching me and one about administrative
and enforcement costs to the town how
will they be paid I also see that the
Bill's requirement to go into effect
towns need to vote on it I shudder at
that a thought I know how my people in
my town think and they're going to view
this as a property tax reduction and
it's going to get voted in without
regard to its long-term consequences or
thought of the overall cost to implement
and administer the collected fee the
amount that small towns could collect is
inconsequential this bill is obviously
being proposed by largest cities as a
money grab for them
why do you think it's okay to burden one
business segment to SCT monies for a
town that's not able to properly balance
their budget the bottom line is it's
going to put an additional burden on me
the town and my fellow legitimate
lodging Partners to collect and remit
yet another tax the proposed legislation
is very careful to call it a fee however
that's just political speak let's call
it what it truly is another tax I urge
you to truly think about what you're
requesting please don't turn New
Hampshire into
taxachusetts thank
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very
much that was the last pink card that I
had so I will ask is there anybody
present who wishes to speak to this bill
who we
do did you fill out a pink card okay
so welcome to Municipal and County
government good morning thank you madam
chair members of the committee for the
record my name is Mike Summers I'm the
president CEO of the New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association I
wasn't going to testify but I wanted to
make a couple of additional points um
obviously here in opposition to uh House
Bill
544 um couple things that I want to
raise that I don't think were mentioned
that I think are worth noting um as um
Heidi just mentioned this bill does not
cover short-term rentals not in the
definition of hotels not in the
definition of occup occupant nowhere in
any of that does this capture the
short-term rentals so ultimately having
heard from the municipal uh
municipalities that testified uh
short-term rentals create the problems
and then the hotels are expected to pay
for them and I think that's unfair and I
think that's a huge problem for the
state and granted there's a problem we
need to figure it out but that's not
necessarily A a fair and Equitable
solution one other thing that I want to
raise for you is that the FTC recently
passed a junk fee Rule and I'm not sure
if you heard about this hotels are
included in this the junk fee rule
basically prohibits us from having
anything outside of outside of taxes uh
Government taxes would have to be
included in the total price of the the
the of the um occupancy so then now
we're in a situation where it is unclear
to us if this fee would then be forced
to be just become part of the price and
therefore ultimately the business owner
is going to be paying this so you know
at that point um it's a bit of tomato
tomato but it essentially just becomes
another bill that the business is going
to have to pay
um I also did not hear anybody really
mention the importance of the commercial
tax base yes I understand res
residential taxes are going up my
personal taxes went up dramatically as
well but I also think that
municipalities forget that these
commercial businesses in all of their uh
jurisdictions are paying an enormous
amount of uh commercial property taxes
and and much of that goes to the town so
we just need to recognize that there is
an awful lot of feedback going into the
towns from commercial tax base from the
meals and rentals tax Etc so there's an
awful lot of money that is being
generated by these businesses from
tourism that are going back to the
municipalities
already um and then the other thing and
this is a question and I don't know the
answer but it's a question for all of
you to as as you deliberate on this
particular piece of legislation is at a
$2 fee the question I have is is that
even going to raise enough money for the
municipality to actually cover the cost
of Enforcement Administration of this
cuz now you're essentially going to have
to have tax or fee collection whatever
you want to call it of by the the
business remitted to the town the town's
going to have to keep track of that
there's going to have to be some sort of
a verification process that I would
assume this then triggers a new audit
process for the business owner which is
another thing that we would have to deal
with so in all of that process my
suspicion is $2 isn't going to cover the
cost for the municipality to even
administer this program which means it
we'll be back here next year the year
after looking at a $5 per night fee
which is obviously one thing that our
industry does not want to see so with
that I will close I'm happy to try to
answer any questions and I will submit a
pink card thank
you thank you questions representative
Elward is recognized for a question
thank you madam chairman and thank you
sir for your testimony um I just lost my
RSA line um seven six and seven defining
a room
facilitator isn't that not applicable to
an Airbnb or short-term rental
um I again I was just looking at the the
definitions that were included at the
start of the bill where it talks about a
hotel and it talks about an occupancy
and in in those references which is what
RSA 78 A3 something in those references
it just specifically outlines as hotels
followup Madam
chair yes yes thank you um if you do
78- a colon 3 Roman
facilitator it is any person who makes a
room available
for
occupancy so under you I'm sorry I don't
have the bill in front of me so I'm
speaking from the hip a little bit here
but um I looked specifically at the
definitions the two definitions listed
at the start of the bill which speaks to
hotel and it speaks to occupant and
under occupant in the statute which I
believe is uh 12 XI means any person who
for rent paid uses possesses or has a
right to use or possess any room in a
hotel under any leas concession permit
right of access so in in that I in my
reading it's just for um but but again
you're the the policy committee on this
I'm just raising our concerns and and
issues thank you thank you further
questions representative Gilman is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question um I understand the um the view
of this being a an attack on a
particular line of business um but my
question to you is wood lodgings and
other other services um or similar
services
uh be able to support what you do if you
don't have the infrastructure of the
fire and police and water and sewer fair
question um but we are also of the
opinion that the rooms of meals tax that
municipalities receive now is for that
very purpose is to support that
infrastructure for tourism and I would
also say that people don't come to New
Hampshire to stay in a hotel people come
to New Hampshire to hike bike snowmobile
ski whatever it might be there is no
fees charged any of them on any of that
activity it's just the lodging
properties well and restaurants as
well thank you further
questions seeing none thank you thank
much so um at this time the chair will
recognize representative Gilman to
sheets thank you madam chair um on the
remote sign in there were four in
support and four opposed and you might
want to take a look at them because two
of them don't apply to this bill so um
and on the blue sheet today uh three in
support and zero
opposed thank you and with that the
public hearing on House Bill 544 local
God
thank
that so at this time the committee is
schedule so um just would like to note
that so we
we may need to keep um track of time
maybe not we'll see how it goes but at
this time the chair will open the public
hearing on House Bill 125 relative to
electing straford County Commissioners
at
large and the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor representative Horan welcome
back thank you very much I'm
representing Timothy Horan from straford
County District 10 which is the town of
Durham um it's in um and I'm interested
of full disclosure it's in the same
county commissioner District which
recently reelected commissioner mlar
who's sitting behind me and I supect may
have a pink card in so um for he's been
serving many many terms since he was
very young and doing a great job so
um and uh the my my bill has uh I will
say my bill has one two three four five
six sponsors all of them from straford
County and the current redistricting
plan um I'm going to point out what I
think are some deficiencies in it but I
will say every town is included and
every ward in the three cities they're
all included and actually it also does
meet the basic statistical requirements
for district so it's uh it could have
been worse but so up until the most
recent election cycle straford County
elected his three County Commissioners
at large it was the only County did this
has been doing this um I've heard since
1865 anyway a very very long time and um
so I may be prejudiced but I think
that's how all the smaller counties
should choose their Commissioners um
notwithstanding the remarks I made about
how it is easy to divide grafting County
into into three districts but I think
probably even Grafton County um you know
there there's a case being made for even
having that County as an at large
District now straford county is unique
because there really is no good way to
divide the county up into three people
pieces I mean maybe it's better than
what we're talking about a few minutes
ago but um it's two largest cities are
Rochester and Dover they have almost
exactly the same number of residents
they're reach about 25% of the total
population Trafford County
geographically it's the smallest county
in the state its population is uh is
about a in fact I think it's exactly
average we're exactly very close to
exactly 10% of the county of the total
population of the state and the red
rcking plan hly pass in 2023 as I said
it could have been much worse but it did
meet some basic statistical standards
it's really not a good plan at all um
this proposed District 2 the one where I
live and commissioner M Lis lives I it's
not even contiguous except in the very
loosest sense of the term contiguous
although I will say in all fairness we
have drawn other districts that relied
on the same thing so it's um if you if
if you look at the map it uh it's
contiguous because there's one point
where I forget exactly which Ward it is
in Dover and Durham meet out in the
middle of the the Bellamy River
underwater so it's not really a
contiguous District but Stanford County
uh consists of three cities and 10 Towns
all of which are actually included in
the the current County redistricting
County Commissioner plans at least every
every town and every Ward and every city
does at least have a county
commissioner um one of those 10 Towns
Durham where I live is for almost all
practical purposes City the only really
significant differences in terms of How
It's governed between Durham and the
three cities is that it calls itself a
town it lacks a mayor it just has a Town
Council and a city manager and it has no
Wards and the third difference is
probably crucial for the current
discussion we're having because the lack
of wards meant there was no way to carve
Durham up between multiple electric
electoral districts and um I was
actually living in Grafton County when
they made the change over but I I seem
to recall that that may have been one of
the reasons why
they decided to have just a town with no
Wards so like it wouldn't get they
wouldn't have to worry about it being uh
subdivided between multiple they weren't
probably weren't thinking about County
Commissioner districts but certainly
between multiple State Rep districts so
we do like
um we we do like having it having like
at least four reps including myself all
to ourselves and not splitting them up
with some other city so we um Durham is
actually significantly larger than the
third the smallest city which the
Summers where so we have uh oh it's 12%
of population Sumer worth only has 9% of
population they do have five Wards to
work with and the three cities in Durham
collectively comprise 71% of the
County's
population um so there was some talk
about that the towns needed more
representation on the uh in the in the
uh when they passed the three District
plan although it didn't the plan they
passed didn't really do that but it's
highly unusual to pass a redistricting
plan in the middle of a 10 year census
cycle and of course it's probably highly
red unusual to resend the redistricting
plan and have an single at large
District the middle of 10e census cycle
but we're going back to what was uh
taken up during the normal process for
redistricting so redistricting bills
normally they're only taken up
immediately after desial census such as
the 2020 census which we had 5 years ago
or the 2030 census which is coming up
pretty soon at least hopefully coming up
pretty soon everything is kind of
Uncertain Nationwide but um the issue of
changing the large election of the
Strafford County Commissioners never
came at all up at all during the
redistricting debate which was uh in 20
I say here in the last few months of
2021 and the first half of 2022 and I
was not on the redistricting committee
but I followed all the meetings closely
and I remember the one where they dealt
with the County Commissioners they just
sort of approved the at large District
in about three minutes you know it was
not this was not a major uh this was not
a major controversy and certainly before
that when they had the various hearing
ings and the rest of the
process um nobody asked for it you know
nobody uh you know this was not
something that anybody said Gee we
really should divide Stanford County the
three commission County Commissioners
districts the people are happy with the
at large District um and so that was
just something basically no one ever
asked for except for a few a few members
of the county delegation not even
anything close to majority the county
delegation and uh so this is just
something certain nobody in the public
asked for this and in fact uh in the
convoluted boundary the three new
districts don't make any no sense at
first glance but they do I said they do
uh bring the population deviation of the
redistricting plan within the standard
like there's a 5% population deviation
so it does meet the basic uh it and it
does meet the basic statistical
standards and um of course if that's
what you're worried about if that's the
if that's the U justification for
drawing the county commissioner
districts way they are um if you have a
single at large district and this you
know it's just a three member
multi-member district
that that reduces a population deviation
even further to zero so if what you want
is reduce the population deviation of
what we had the at large district is the
is the uh is the way to go so and um
representative Horgan
um you're at the five minute limit would
you be able to to it up I just had well
two more things I've one okay I um I am
the so please return to Stafford
County's tradition a good tradition of
electing three County Commissioners from
a single at large District but also I
have to mention I passed around a second
sheet of paper along with my written
testimony which is a Amendment to the
RSA 6559 which we had a floor debate
which uh probably most of the members
which I I I subjected the uh members of
the Full House to it most probably had
no idea what the heck we were talking
about but I I respect y this is a
related issue to this is this would be a
Germaine amendment to my bill and I uh I
think I think what I came up with is a
very simple solution which makes the
minimum number of changes uh to the
existing law so basically just keeps the
standard of having a domicile in the
county but then adds the uh then adds
the requirement that if you're a county
commissioner it simply says You must
have a domicile in the district from
which uh you of course I changed he to
he or she is chosen so the uh what we
passed the other day is is well one
problem was it talks about for what
you're elected but County Commissioners
can be chosen because if there's a
vacancy in any County Office including
Commissioners actually the county
delegation chooses the we don't have a
special election they the county
delegation choses it and I know this
from firsthand experience because we
actually had a member of the county
commissioner di several years ago and we
we the county delegation elected the
replacement County Commissioner so
that's uh that's I think that I
respectfully think that's probably a
better solution than what was uh what
was approved by the house and we're
certainly um certainly I certainly would
urge you to seriously consider
regardless of what you feel about the
underlying Bill sending that to the Full
House and I think that's a better
solution than what we have it's also
something that's probably more likely to
pass muster on the other side of the
wall if and when it gets over to the
other body so thank you very much your
time and thank you representative Morgan
I should would have asked for six
minutes if I knew I needed more than the
see seeing none thank you thank
you and the last pink card that we have
for this bill
is commissioner
back thank you madam chairman I'm going
brief I'm not going to repeat what
representative Horgan said the the
County Commissioners in straford County
were elected at large for about 160
years during the redistricting process
there was not one member of the public
who spoke and said that they wanted this
public later
on uh in the last session the
legislature decided in it in its wisdom
to divide straffic County up into
districts when they did so they divided
half they determined where I lived tried
to figure out how they could Jerry
Mander the
county and divided Rochester in half
divided do in half now I've been through
five redistricting since I've been in
public office from straford County five
of
them normally the county delegation as I
mentioned earlier would meet to discuss
whether or not they wanted to do this or
not whe it was a good idea in those five
instances it was determined by the
county delegation in those five
instances in the last 50 years not to
change the way the County Commissioners
were elected simply because they had to
divide cities in half in order to
meet the goal of having equal
populations so as I had mentioned in my
earlier testimony most of these things
are politically motivated it was
politically motivated to divide straford
County up in a district
they disenfranchised 990,000 voters so
let's so I'm just want to take one
minute to tell you what the result of
that
was the sponsors of the initial bill
said that they wanted more repres
representation from the towns even
though in the last 50 years we've had a
representative on the County Commission
from a town it's just the way it
worked the results of the last
election you had ended up with two
County Commissioners from
do because they split do in
half added a few Towns now we got two
County Commissioners from do and one
from Farmington the prior commission we
had myself from Dover a commissioner
from Rochester and one from Rollinsford
which was a small
town if it was the in the sponsor's
intent to make sure to ensure that the
towns the 10 towns in straford County
had equal
representation which I think was a bogus
argument they should have designed a
district with those 10 Towns in
it they never did that it was
politically motivated it was designed to
get me and I'm not quite sure it worked
thought so as I mentioned my earlier
testimony on the past bill you're going
to continue to see these bills 95% of
these bills that have generated are
politically motivated and not and
they're not in the interest of the
people they disenfranchised 990,000
voters in straford County who had the
right and the ability to control who
their executive branch of County
government was they took that right away
from them that's what they did let's
just call the spade a shovel for a
minute here that's what they did in an
attempt to get
me now I've been County Commissioner for
21 terms I've been nominated by the
opposite Party by the Republican Party
times and it takes an Act of the
legislature and it passes by one vote in
the last session by one member who
wasn't even legally voting so in any
event one final
point the cities and towns and the
counties are creatures of the state you
folks know
this they exist solely to provide
services on behalf of the
state and historically what we've done
is we've had the county delegations meet
and during that census process determine
how we were going to govern ourselves
these attempts in the off years and also
the Supreme Court in New Hampshire ruled
that the public the public was entitled
to
stability some
stability in this
process what they created in straford
County the last election was anything
but stability it created
instability and as a result of it you
took away people's rights to vote which
I find abhorent
I don't think it's constitutional I
think it's wrong on its surface but
because the county is a creature of the
state this the county the legislation
can do what it wants with it and I get
that I get that but you have to ask
yourself a question which never happens
here most of the time when you take an
action you never revisit it to think
what what was the result of that
action I can tell you what the result of
the action was this time you ended up
with two County Commissioners from Dover
and I can also tell you in the future
you'll either e going to have two County
Commissioners from DOA or two County
Commissioners from Rochester because
that's the way they divided it up in
this present
scheme in an attempt in a political
attempt to get me
removed and I told them well maybe that
should be up to the vot is to decide
whether they want me removed or
not in the end they never even feel that
a candidate against me their own party
nominated
me so what's so so what's this all about
I mean in the in the end what's serving
the public here in straford County if
they really want to know how people
straford County feel I I received
hundreds and hundreds of phone calls
from people who've been voting for me
for over 40 years who couldn't vote for
me anymore and they were confused they
didn't think I was running anymore there
was a lot of confusion there's still a
lot of confusion and that confusion
remains if they're really interested in
doing what the people of straford County
want put a referendum pass a bip force a
referendum on the people of straford
County as to whether they want this or
not or ask the county delegation like we
historically done in this state for
decades and decades and decades as to
how they wish to have their County
Commissioners
elected that's a simple way to to solve
the problem politically and I'll accept
any result that that comes of it but to
do this back door this back door
political
maneuvering doesn't serve our state well
it doesn't serve the people of straford
County that I've represented for 42
years correctly actually for 50 years if
you get right down to it 48 40 almost 49
years
I believe the historical way we do we've
done business in this state makes
sense and it should be returned to that
and if the county delegation wants to
change it they should come to the
legislature and tell you so if there's
such a human cry to change the way
things are done in straford just like
this problem that you're got in
Grafton all these things have been done
over the course of history because of
political
retribution and that's just the facts
you look at it historically that are the
facts so now we sit here every few years
and we try to straighten it
out that's what we try to do so in any
event Madam chairman I've spoke long
enough but that disenfranchise of those
990,000 voters really irritates me more
than anything I don't care about me okay
whether I serve or not serve at this
point I'm too old but the bottom line is
the bottom line is those people are
disenfranchising you and the legislature
took away their right and I find that
important so with that Madam chairman
thank you thank you commissioner mcis
other questions representative Walker is
recognized for a question
commissioner the 90,000 voters that
you're uh you're referring to where are
they at where are they at in the county
they're the entire voting public of the
county meaning everyone who's registered
to vote in straford
County okay which includes Democrats
Republicans Communists socialists Green
Party People Libertarians I mean the
entire 90 roughly 90,000 I say that they
didn't because you
have
uh representative Walker it's not a
debate with with the speaker you could
ask a question yeah a followup did you
have a follow-up question no I'll retain
questions seeing none thank you thank
you madam chairman members of the
so um I will ask at this time is there
anybody present who wishes to speak on
this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do so seeing none the
chair will recognize representative
Gilman to report out the blue
sheets thank you madam chair uh on the
remote sign in there were uh five in
support and four in
opposition and on the blue sheet there
thank you representative Gilman and with
that um I will call close the public
125 so it looks like we caught up with
on our schedule and this time the
committee will break for lunch and we
will resume public hearings at 1
you
e
me
I'm only laughing because we've been
you
know
e
good afternoon the New Hampshire House
of Representatives municipal and County
government
committee has convened after lunch to
resume publicly noticed hearings and we
will be beginning with our um Bill
noticed for
1M before I open the hearing on that
bill I would like to remind everybody
that in order to stay on schedule today
the chair will allow for up to five
minutes for Bill introduction followed
by questions and answers and then up to
3 minutes will be given for inperson
public testimony with additional time
allotted for questions and answers if
the speaker allows the vice chair will
be keeping track of time due to the fact
that we have uh a number of pink cards
so when you the time has
expired he will note that by holding up
a pink card in at which point I we would
ask that you um conclude your
testimony and if a speaker has written
testimony please indicate such and
distribute it to representative kazinski
and we'll pass that around the
table additionally if a speaker has more
information that they wish to share with
the committee then also let us know and
you may follow up with written testimony
sent to each Committee Member via email
and then as a final reminder when you um
come to provide public testimony State
for the record your name who you
represent in your position on the
bill okay and one other thing that I
would like to say with regards to House
Bill
123 the me the the matter before us is
the Bold language so it is the changes
to RSA 795 so to be clear we are not not
here to um to get input and have a
hearing on the carbon sequestration
program per se it is the bill is about
taxing wood or Timber that is enrolled
in the carbon sequestration
program so I just wanted to make that
that clear so that your um testimony is
so at this time I will open the public
hearing on House
Bill 123 enabling municipalities to tax
standing wood and Timber on land used
sequestration the chair would like to
recognize representative Davis the prime
sponsor of this
legislation good afternoon and welcome
thank you madam chair uh members of the
committee for the record my name is
representative Arnold Davis I'm the vice
chair of resource Recreation and
development I live in Miland New
Hampshire and I proudly represent Coos
District
2 a total disclosure I'm I'm an old hick
from northern Coos so the the testimony
you're about to hear probably won't be
as polished as the people coming behind
me but I'll try my best to muddle
through this I'm here to introduce House
Bill 123 it's a simple bill that does
one thing it adds carbon sequestration
to
RSA 79 which is Timber tax does not
create a new tax but simply adds carbon
projects to the yield tax section of RSA
79 semicolon 3 this bill does not
attempt to change RSA 79 in any other
way except for adding carbon projects to
align with Timber harvesting allowing
for carbon projects to pay their fair
share in New Hampshire standing Timber
on large wood Lots is considered part of
the real estate it has a value that is
taxable and would show up on your yearly
property
tax before Timber
tax the assessing officials would Cruise
these properties each year and assess
the value of the standing Timber
as you can imagine this was very
cumbersome and probably not very
accurate also some Property Owners would
actually clearcut to as a way to
circumvent paying the property taxes
grossly mismanaging their
forest in order to remedy these problems
Timber tax RSA 79 was enacted instead of
assessing the the standing Timber each
year you would only be taxed on the
timber when you did a Timber Harvest at
that time you would pay a 10% yield tax
not a severance tax but a yield tax this
made things much simpler for the
assessing officials and the system was
much more
accurate so this worked well for 75
years now there's another way of doing
business it's also a way for the land
owners to circumvent from paying their
tax on the standing Timber now let me be
clear about this there is nothing
illegal about
this it's just a
loophole if you enter into a carbon
project you enter into an agreement to
either not cut the standing timber for a
certain period of time or at least
greatly reduce these Timber Cuts if your
deal is with the California compliance
market then the contracts are for a 100
years this means a carbon project this
means as carbon projects become more
popular the loss of Timber tax will
create a hardship for many towns in New
Hampshire this bill bill intends to keep
Hall New Hampshire is 84% forested we
are the second most forested state in
the Union per capita behind Maine this
is not by accident it's from proper
forestry management I'd salute any any
Forester in the room here today for the
work they've
done we do not only man manage our
forest for wood products industry we
also manage for wildlife habitat for
recreation for forest fire management
and
mitigation and so like before Timber tax
when some land owners would clearcut
their property to avoid paying taxes I
believe not implementing best forestry
management practices by not being able
to harvest Timber due to carbon deals
could be equally as dangerous to the
health and well-being of New Hampshire's
Forest
this bill is not intended to infringe
upon landowner rights this bill simply
would require you to pay the same yield
tax for the revenue you generate from
carbon sequestration in a similar manner
that you do when harvesting timber in
many cases the carbon credits are worth
more than the timber
itself this bill does not attempt to
alter RSA 79 in any way except to add
carbon sequestration to it all Ru making
will remain the same certain
forms like intent to cut may be intent
to sequester cabin uh you you when it
talks about stumpage it would be in this
tonnage now there may be some not in
support of this bill some people are not
in favor of Timber tax at
all it's not that they actually oppose
the bill they just want to pay the
timber tax yet they enjoy the benefit of
the assessing officials not assessing
their standing Timber each year this
bill will move us forward to align
carbon sequestration with Timber
harvesting this bill has two main object
objectives to keep municipalities whole
with the loss of Timber tax and to allow
Timber harvesting to be on a fair
playing field with carbon projects
protecting the economic development of
the North country in the Tim Timber
Hampshire it is very important to
remember this is not a new tax it is
still Timber tax it is simply a way to
keep a fairly new way of doing business
from circumventing around paying their
property tax to the towns and to push
for best forestry management
practices so thank you and I would be
happy to answer any questions thank you
representative Davis I I had one quick
question yes so um we have before us an
amendment to this bill and I assume that
your your bill introduction spoke to to
this to this amendment yes thank you
representative representative Gerard is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair thank you representative for
taking my question um looking through
your bill I completely understand what
what the purposes of this currently in
the I believe 795 or I apologize I got
the wrong number I'm pretty sure um that
any standing Timber that does go to get
to maturity that's not being cut there's
still a possibility of getting 10% tax
on that currently according to the law
is that correct thank you for your
question yes that's exactly
correct
so 795 it was it was too I looked at
that for so long and it was too messy to
put it there you have to the the
assessing officials have to deem there's
a shortfall they have to to uh figure
that the the timber is mature there's so
many arguments to this that I thought it
would be best to put it under the yield
tax section where it talks about when
you harvest your Timber you pay a 10%
yield and that's the payback the subsidy
that the town has allowed you all these
years of of not not going out and
assessing your Timber like they used to
so that that does have a place there
it's never it it's never actually been
invoked but uh and I spoke with Dr a
number of times and they they find it
hard it's very hard for them to deal
with that the the way that's worded so I
I think it's much cleaner being under 79
it it's actually
79 uh semicolon
3-c is where this would be implemented
and it it's just much cleaner okay
follow up yes but I I do have one one
comment so your question yeah did
pertain to the bill as written and I'm
not sure if he made the connection but
he spoke to the amendment and that's
where that reference of the 79 colon 3C
comes in okay okay so yes followup um as
again I'm assuming this studies out
there how much um Timber has it been cut
back since that I believe we just
started it was 2013 they started using
sequestration up there I just was
curious if we know um there's people
behind me that are going to have some
figures but but historically before 2013
I want to say on
average um it it wasn't the current
owners that own it now but it was
another owner when he they got into
carbon sequestration before that the the
average cut I believe was around
$175,000 a year that they paid in Timber
tax to the town of Pittsburgh now also
stewartown in Clarkville this property
covers those too so I don't know the
figures to those towns so Pittsburgh a
town of 800
people uh to take a loss of
$175,000 a year off one parcel that's 5%
of their budget so that's a big hit the
town has two choices they can cut their
budget by
$175,000 or they can bump up the 800
people's property tax to make up for the
subsidy that is that's not being paid
back here it's not like I said it's
nothing illegal it's just a loophole
that's that needs to be closed up for to
put carbon sequestration on the same
playing field with Timber
harvesting thank you for your answer
yeah further
questions representative
Colby thank you madam chair um thank you
for taking my question I'm just trying
to
point homeowners uh small properties can
utilize carbon
sequestration
um how do you not apply this une in
unequally you know if I if I have 10
acres um and I choose not
to I choose to enroll it but I'm also
paying property tax on my home
portion uh the rest is in current use
and how do I know that I'm not going to
be subject to this when I'm only have 10
acres versus someone who may have
2,000 thank you for your
question I so you're let's say you have
10 acres and you do a Timber Harvest
you're going to pay 10% Timber tax on
that on that
Harvest uh if you do a cin project why
wouldn't you do the same I I just think
it it should be fair across the board
and what these small Apostles like
that I I guess you could bundle them up
but I I uh not so worried about that if
you go to Northern Coos you can find a
10,000 acre pel of land pretty handily
and those are the ones that that down
the road what's going to happen if
everybody goes to a Cobin first
initiative what's going to happen to the
the timber industry so
we're still cutting the same amount of
wood whether it's
locally the wood products industry is
not going away we need lumber we need
furniture we need toilet paper we need
you know anything that's made from from
wood
so I'll give you an example in my
hometown of my there's a company called
myin
Lumber I don't know I should know the
number of people they employ it's quite
a few and they used to procure 20% of
their lumber from Pittsburgh it's been a
couple years they haven't gotten any
lumber from Pittsburgh which is locally
so now they're they're figuring ways to
bring this the same amount of logs from
New York by Rail and by truck into milin
New
Hampshire
so until they they got this process
working they were down to four days a
week so if you work there you missed out
on on 52 days of work last year which is
a pretty big hit for somebody in small
town like that for
anybody
so I I can't imagine I mean arguably
Trucking those logs from New York to mil
and New Hampshire when you used to get
them next door has to be offsetting
that's called leakage they have to be
offsetting the the credits you're
getting from from carbon sequestration I
I
uh you
know I hope I answered your
questions representative
gr thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question um do you know
what the percentag is of this land
that's owned by corporations versus
individuals I I do not know that I I
mean and I'm not picking on this this
prop it just happens to be this is
146,000 acre parcel it's the largest
single parcel in New Hampshire and it's
it's an easy target I uh because it's in
the news from you know all these figures
answer representative frock is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair representative Davis thank
you for coming um as I understand
it uh if I own 1100 Acres of Timber when
I harvested that Timber after
what 10 20 30 years depending on the
species I would pay the yield tax is
that correct that's correct uh followup
yes if I put that same 1100 Acres of
Timberland
into um the carbon sequestration
program how often would I be taxed on it
would it be every year or every 20 years
or how is that going to work it you
would be taxed when there is a yield
so some there's a lot of differences a
lot lot of diff every contract may be a
little different but let's say you you
sequestered I'm just going to make up a
number a thousand tons but you didn't
sell any you would report to the town
you have a th000 tons sequestered the
next year you do another thousand
and you sell 1,800 then you would report
that to the town and you would you would
yield
followup I'll allow a second followup
yes thank you um so is this likely to
even out the revenue stream for
towns well definitely with the loss of
Timber tax it it's going to be a high
ship on most of at least in in Coos
especially we have a lot of
unincorporated places and that's there
some of them that's their major Revenue
the uh the commission there's a
commissioner here that'll probably speak
on this today how this is going to
affect the unincorporated places but
definitely further
you the chair now now calls um two
people that together that wish to um I
provide testimony together and that
would be Mr Mark Brady and Mr Ray Gorman
and following that I will call Ms
Meredith
Hatfield so good afternoon and welcome
there we go good afternoon um thank you
for having us and to be listening to us
so my name is Ray Gman I live in cook
New Hampshire I Am The District 3 County
Commissioner but I'm here speaking with
the County Commissioners all three of us
unanimous in our thoughts and what this
process is right now um one of the
things that that this bill for us is
that
K
county is so heavily wooded and
so lumbering has always been a major
part of what we do we have the Mills we
have everything that goes on around them
and the actions that happen around them
with the roads being built Etc in K
County we have
23 unincorporated towns and there's only
two other Incorporated towns I or three
in
yeah in the whole state uh 26 is on okay
Mark will back up some of the numbers
but these are towns with very little
population but huge
Forest you know water streams all that
stuff and they've been heavily this is
where lumbering has taken on for years
and years and these communities as we
manage them on the county level the
timberx is a large part of the revenue
from these unincorporated towns as well
as all the other communities that I'm
speaking about but I'm going to speak
specifically today on on Incorporated
towns what how would it affect that now
unincorporated towns have fixed costs
just like everybody else um
ambulance dispatching those are two huge
costs all right and through the years
the unincorporated towns there a the
dispatching dispatching and the
ambulance services are all done by
communities and communities working
together and like when we've gone to get
money to upgrade our dispatch the county
has been very generous at three
different times they have provided the
match for us on grants this money come
from the unincorporated towns who got
their money from the timber tax all
right a huge part of what these
unincorporated towns get for revenues
come from Timber
tax and we've already seen with and I'm
on the board I'm on the 45th parallel
and the dispatch boards representing the
county and our costs are increasing
significantly just like everybody else
you guys know all it's like to to
provide those services but if we lose
our Revenue stream it's going to be a
significant loss to us very important
that you understand that and we believe
strongly here we what we seeing with the
carbon that it's making us very nervous
is that we believe it's it's basically a
complete change in forestry P practices
you're not going to see The Cutting and
so on and so forth but I'm talking about
the revenue today so that reflects the
revenues by we've already seen it in the
upper connectic Connecticut headquarters
where the this that is part a big part
of what's the headed Waters now the
carbon SE equation and The Cutting has
decreased from 30,000 plus to down under
I think last year was 50
we're seeing significant it's a carbon
is credit forestry is a total different
way of doing cutting so that's why we
it's you know I don't want to get off
base because I know what you said at
your beginning remarks but if that
involves the revenue that I'm talking
about now for unincorporated towns as
well as all those communities and the
significant effects like Berlin gorm the
paper mills all right the um all those
if you stop cutting the the um
coold Generation all right the the type
of wood that they use so on and so forth
it will it's a for the northern part in
this region that I represent this is a
major change and we we need to find a
way we to me it's no different you know
we're talking about taxing here that
already
exist and taxing the wood okay revenue
is being made on this wood
from the carbon
credits
okay
y just let me add something my name is
uh Mark Brady uh from Jefferson I'm the
cost County Administrator uh to follow
up on commissioner Gorman a little bit
and put into perspective so what
obviously you know makes Coos unique is
that we have 23 of the 25 unincorporated
places so we really are the center so to
speak of I like to say of of Land
Management in the State uh uh Etc uh our
two main economies today are uh Timber
and our uh ohrv recreational use which
between the two of them it's about uh5
billion total to the state okay and and
we drive a lot of that um regarding the
unincorporated places uh so we did an
analysis I was able to get back an
analysis done by my f by the finance
department to go back to
2009 and the the timber tax uh to the
unincorporated budget over that time
frame from 09 to to through this through
last year is a 20 is
28% so if you were to conceivably start
to phase out
of Timber harvesting and go into carbon
sequestration that's 28% whole
ultimately that there in maybe less
depending upon how fast you go uh that
we lose uh and if you can you can
imagine that actually in 2009 uh uh
Timber was 53% of of the budget's uh
revenue and now it's down to 28% and
that kind of Segways into certainly
what's happened and and you hear a lot
about Connecticut Lake Headwaters and
you hear about it a lot because it's
it's it's the single largest private
piece of property in the state 146,000
acres and it's it's
instrumental to the North country that's
why Senators Greg and and former Senator
Greg and then Governor Shaheen and and
now uh Senator Shaheen decided to get
$33 million of federal and state Monies
to secure an easement to so that it
would be a productive working forest and
the to to go to I think one of the one
of the representatives questions over
here um so when they did that easement
on that property on that property it was
harvesting 40,000
uh Charlie L can probably can probably
knows numbers better than me a little
bit 40,000 uh cords a
year you get into about 2010 2012 and
they register it with carb and you start
to see it starts to to descend down into
the 30s 30,000 courts uh why we've been
so exercised today is because that
property alone well I'm not going to you
know representative Davis mentioned the
implications to Min number etc etc is
now
probably less than 15,000 cords on an
annual basis which has profound
implications to us uh so to go to the
point of the 10% what's fair would we be
be made hold or not most likely we're
not made whole at
10% probably not okay with some of the
economists that that we've used we used
in our response to the state on their
lack of enforcement of the easement um
and I think the another way you have to
look at it as
well having a Timber economy where
you're cutting and you're taking you're
taking product to Mills is different
than a carbon
sequestration economy so to speak based
on that which is a much more static type
of uh existence for the uh uh for the
property for sure uh and I I'm not going
to digress maybe uh others will I don't
want to digress into the implications of
carbon credit per se on all of this but
we're trying to be
agnostic about carbon credit from a from
a public policy perspective of doing
budgets Etc we just want to make it all
work just make it work but if you're
going to go to a carbon credit carbon
first
economy then you're not going to be
doing all the cutting that has a a
trickle on effect actually it has a
multip supplier of 2.3 so for every 100
jobs you get in the timber industry you
have another
230 in the in in the transitional
Downstream you probably don't get that
with carbon sequestration I think that
that's that's probably a pretty fair uh
assumption we want to be agnostic and I
would I would leave you with this last
point if you don't make if you leave the
back door open this is how we view it
because we view it as your circumventing
the the state clearly 75 years ago said
this is what we're going to do we're
going to extract that value that way and
if you don't apply it to carbon you are
de facto incentivizing carbon you are
you are incentivizing people to take the
property and put it in carbon because
well I don't you have to pay 10% why
would I not do that I mean the rational
person would would do that other than
for for obviously some of what would be
good Forest management um but you know
those are this is these issues cut to
the core of us and it is about our tax
base uh for sure it's about us at a
county level you know performing our our
duties that we constitutionally have to
do we run two nursing homes we're the
only county in the state that does that
Etc uh and you know look at the end of
the day you know we say this coos is 20%
of the land area of the state we're the
biggest County and we're 2% of the
population and yet we are the identity
of the state Every Which Way Mount
Washington is the most visited place in
this state Coos generates a million
visitors a
year now we're going to have this tax
that at least there's a direct line to
us if it's if it's if it's here in Coos
and you go Harvest it you're going to
pay that yield tax we know rooms and
meals we're generating over 100 over a
million people that come to Coos rooms
and meals is based on 2% of the
population I mean I'm not I don't want
to give you a sad story on that but my
point
is this this is a
circumvention and this puts carbon if if
you do not include it you're
incentivizing carbon over
over
harvested thank you for your testimonies
questions representative
FR thank you madam
chair
um I don't know an awful lot about the
timber industry um but it would seem to
me that at some point in the life of a
woodlot the timber would reach a maximum
growth and would need to be
harvested and if that is the case at
that
point the harvested Timber would be
taxed yet again so you're taxing it
not oh the thing
about if you do not Harvest it okay and
it just all tumbles down
all right it becomes
useless your for it hasn't been
harvested and if you have normal Forest
practices you were talking about 20 and
30 years ago each time the they the
incentive is whatever is on the ground
that's keeping that carbon so they're
not nowhere's near in a hurry to log May
20 to 30 years they will harvest no as
near as much as they would if there were
a regular Forest under a regular Forest
program I I hope that makes sense yeah
and and just to we use a as a rule of
thumb for us and uh there are others
here that probably maybe can can answer
this better but you you enter into a car
a carb contract which is what
Connecticut Lakes is on okay which is
that's California Air Resource Board
okay so you've imported that we've
imported that that those priorities here
in New Hampshire so that requires I
believe a 100-year commitment on that
project so we view that as basically
three Cuts you know let's say every 30
years you know whatever so it's it would
be three
Cuts additional
questions I had a a follow-up question
so to be clear under the uh carbon
sequestration program it sounds like
typically it's 100
years the timber
tied up for a 100 years so to be clear
there's no cutting is that correct or
can you cut no that's that's not correct
and I think I think either uh Mr Hackley
or even uh Charlie Le can get into it
more there has to be some Forest
management uh I think where the sticking
point is and it's an excellent question
representative because I think it's
really we I would I would pose that we
you as a state have not vetted all of
this probably as clearly as it needs to
be vetted so we all understand exactly
where we are on this um but there is
some Forest management that's done but
then it it gets into the question of
well okay well what is it and what's
proper and what's not and that was some
of the that's certainly been some of the
discussions if you would go to the the
the citizen uh the Connecticut
headquarters citizens committee with
some of the discussion and you listen to
Aurora's
Forester and proper proper Forest
management I I have a feeling you can
have some on one extreme that are going
to have very minimal there'll be others
probably that would be a little bit more
aggressive there is one other point
that's just gnawing here that was raised
by one of the representatives over here
and it was actually raised last year
when we testified and I don't think we
we we've nowhere begun to grasp and
there is the difference between
the 100 Acre owner and for instance in
the with us where we do have a we do
know the bigger pieces of property okay
and I can I didn't bring it with me but
certainly if you want that I'd be
prepared I can provide you with that you
can see it we see it okay we know where
the the big pieces of property are and
that's what we're scared about we don't
at the end of the day if they want to do
an aggregation and take up a and there
are firms that do aggregate that get
smaller pieces of property and roll them
up together and that's that's not what
we're really talking about you have to
deal with the way you have to deal with
it statutorily get it in Legally and and
whatever but we're talking about the
bigger pieces of property that will that
have begun to transform Coos by the lack
of cutting in Connecticut lakes and it
won't take much you can take couple
pieces of property out of line and you
fundamentally change everything and we
have haven't even discussed access to
the property because you know there are
a lot a lot of these firms like
Aurora that you know they don't like the
ohvs they create a lot of erosion they
chew it up you know and so what's going
to be their disposition Aurora said vert
on Trails will keep the existing Trails
we want no more Trails no more so I mean
there's a lot of questions
there thank you further
grund thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um so it
might be a a couple parts for
clarification
the the people who own the land are they
individuals or corporations that you are
particularly talking about right now the
bigger pieces of parcels by and large
are are comp corporations are
corporations okay because I was I was
wondering like if it's a person then
they're having a contract with
California there's probably income on
that contract that they're paying tax on
so I trying to understand if this be a
double tax to somebody if they're paying
income and then this 10% yeah I'm sorry
I mean to interrupt you uh that's one of
the questions about Aurora I think to be
honest with you that we've had over are
they paying any tax at all okay part of
our issue was and why we had to go Coos
was forced
to go get our attorneys to look at the
terms of the easement and see where we
are in
2024 was
that the most basic reporting on that
has not been done by the property owners
and the ones before before even Aurora
to the
state so I don't it's a fair
question additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
at this time the chair would like to
call Representative ulette and I do
apologize your card was hiding and we
have a um precedent where we call upon
Representatives first so that if they
have business that they're tending to in
other committees they they can get back
to that so welcome to Municipal and
County
government thank you madam chair and
committee members uh you've made my day
I've never been accused of
hiding I'll be very
brief uh House Bill 123
hb13 is in addition to irsa 79 the the
timber tax and it needs to be changed uh
to keep up on our current times the
timber tax was
originally uh conceived and instituted
in the 40s it was a creative way to deal
with standing
Timber and uh is continued to work well
allowing Timber owners to avoid the
yield tax on the timber until the timber
is
cut um our world has and continues to
change hp23 is nothing more than a
reflection of today's varying Timber
Market when you sell your carbon in
Woodland excuse me when you sell your
carbon in your wood lot in essence
you're selling the trees without cutting
them uh the trees are tied up anywhere
from 40 to 100 years which is about two
to three Harvest Cycles in the average
New Hampshire wood lot in late in the
late 1800s and early 1900s New Hampshire
was over 90% cleared land today we're
over 80% forested our Foresters have
done a great job managing our our
forests the bill keeps the town's whole
by collecting Revenue created by selling
the carbon if you do not collect the
carbon the if you do not collect on the
carbon sales just as if it was harvested
Timber the other taxpayers in town are
essentially subsidizing the Timberland
owners through higher property
taxes this is a very
complex uh
topic uh this is a another part of the
carbon industry we're trying to work
through last year representative Davis
and myself uh um wrote A bill had it uh
signed into law to set up a registry in
New Hampshire so that people who are
selling Carbon on their Timberlands have
to sign in this registry because we have
no idea who's part of the uh carbon
sales uh we have no idea who's uh
sequestering their car carbon we have no
idea who it's being sold to we have no
idea what the value is we have no idea
if these companies that a California
company is buying the carbon selling it
to a Michigan company holding land in
New Hampshire if they're even paying the
the New Hampshire business s the New
Hampshire business tax we have no idea
so last year was the first step is to
was to set up a registry so we know
who's in the carbon
game um and uh and it's passed um
this
year um you know this is the next part
of it uh as one of the representatives
had asked if you sell your uh get paid
for selling your your carbon and then
you sell your Timber do you pay the tax
twice absolutely and I'll tell you why
because you sold your Timber once to as
carbon you've sold it you've collected
your
money 50 years 80 years later when you
cut your Timber you've sold it again so
youve sold that actual piece of Timber
twice and you've gained income twice you
should pay the tax
twice um sequestering carbon is just a
new way to sell your Timber so let's
pass hb123 and let RSA 79-5 the timber
tax continue to do its job thank you
very much and I glad to take any
questions thank you representative Vette
questions for the
representative representative Colby is
recognized for a question thank you
madam CH thank you representative
um
how can a property simultaneously exist
under current use status as well as
being enrolled in a carbon sequestration
program
absolutely um and the
um as representive Davis had mentioned
we're not so concerned with a mom and
popop piece of land at 30 40 acres it's
it's a bigger guys that are are part of
it but it it does concern everybody and
it is I disagree with some of our
previous speakers this is a Statewide
property a Statewide issue it's not just
a North Country issue because there are
a lot of property owners in the southern
part of the state with 500 to Thousand
Acres and it's going to affect us
all um uh current use is a great thing
and and uh that was put in to give the
owners of their property the
availability to keep them without losing
them to taxes um and it's very possible
possible to have a piece of property
that uh part of your timers and uh in
the carbon program and part of it is
just a standard um Harvest program like
we have today um that the the property
owners have property rights and they
need to be
protected but at the same time uh we
need to protect our our our towns and
and like I said I think that the carbon
uh is just uh an evolution of the Timber
business and um should be still
795 additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
much next the chair recognizes executive
counselor
Kenny welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you it's been a
while for the record uh my name is Joe
Kenny district one executive counselor
so
I represent from the Canadian border all
the way down to the University New
Hampshire and Durham so you can imagine
my uh representative seat is very
Diversified and you know broken down
into three distinct regions and one of
those regions is a North Country but I
also represent Carol County bellnap and
parts of Grafton and so land is
plentiful and so this topic of uh carbon
sequestration wasn't even a topic um
five years ago in New Hampshire
but because of the Connecticut
Headwaters property it kind of sounded
the alarm um that if we can't Harvest
our land or if we can't assess uh carbon
sequestration um then forever our uh
woodland culture and economy is forever
changed and so what is New Hampshire and
Northern New Hampshire a lot of the
economy is based off of logging wood
products um low energy power plants we
rely heavily on on the uh Forest economy
so when I testified on a bill over a
year ago in my testimony I I thought it
was necessary to have a registry to
bring out the fact that who was
participating in the carbon offset tax
credit program because I was curious I
wanted to know what was the incentive
and what I found out was that our state
you know 84% Forest
California
33% Nevada in the low
teens North Dakota South Dakota two 2
and 3% that suddenly the Northeast was a
target for this program because we have
effectively managed our forest in a
great way over the years and there's a
lot of prospecting going on in our state
currently I believe there's about 10
people that are on the registry or
companies that are part of this um
carbon offset tax tax credit program so
that let you know that there are large
swaps of land that are in this program
already that have long-term contracts
that until about two years ago or a year
and a half ago we knew nothing about it
in the state that would be like saying
that the current use program in the
state of New Hampshire that no one would
know which property owners were in
current use that was the equivalent and
we all know we can go into our town hall
and look up who is in current use with
our local neighbor and we know that our
local guy has got to get intent to cut
and they have to check in with the local
assessor in the town hall to make sure
it's all in the up and up and
furthermore it goes to dncr and the uh
force and land to make sure the Dr and
everybody's informed of this intent to
cut and that it's it's carried through
very
transparent very understandable it's
been around since
1949 we knew nothing about carbon offset
tax credit program that was transported
into New Hampshire it's this Market that
they've created for carbon sequestration
and apparently there's there are a few
folks out there who want to make a
killing on it unfortunately it's
impacted our culture in Northern New
Hampshire and around the
state so my sense is this is
fairness fairness fairness fairness that
the local municipalities have a way to
assess the carbon sequestration registry
program so that the fair revenue is
brought to the town and that folks and
who own large swaps of land do not
Escape their responsibility of providing
a yield tax to that municipality that's
all we're really looking for when I look
at this bill here it's a fairness bill
that's all it is because um the Town
Administrator from C County Mark Brady
made the point there would be a lot of
people who like to escape that tax who
would participate in this program and
they would like to tie up the forest and
they like to make their money they
wouldn't contribute to the local
community they wouldn't pay the fair
share and they would make more money and
profit well we just want fairness
through this bill throughout the state
and I would also like to
add that
um I think when you look at New
Hampshire and where we're at in many
ways we're leading the nation on policy
changes on this particular new economy
the carbon offset tax credit economy if
you
will because many other states are way
behind and they're looking to New
Hampshire to come up with Solutions on
this topic Governor aot is very involved
in this topic she's she made mention in
her inaugural speech that she's
concerned about the Connecticut
headquarters and she wants to make sure
we get the agreement right so that we
don't wipe out the forest industry in
the North country by tying up the land
so I I've got enough knowledge on this
that could be dangerous um like all of
us we're learning as we're going along
with this particular new program in the
state of New Hampshire we all want to
have a great environment we're the most
livable state in the country we have
these great natural resources the
mountains the Lakes the oceans but the
way to really protect our state through
this program is
fairness and the whole purpose of the uh
Timber tax program in 1949 was for
conservation purposes and so I think if
we're able to create a yield tax for
carbon
sequest uh sequestration uh registration
that we will in turn be adding to that
conservation Spirit here in New
Hampshire so with that I'll take any
questions Madam chairman
thank you councelor Kenny questions for
the
counselor seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes Ms
Meredith
government thank you very much um my
name is Meredith Hatfield and I'm with
the nature conservancy and we do oppose
um this legislation I have not had a
chance to um fully consider the
amendment um so if our views change I
will certainly follow up with additional
written
testimony we deeply appreciate um the
challenges of our some of our Northern
and rural areas of the state and we
certainly want to be part of a
conversation to make sure that those
towns are kept whole um we work with
another organization the American Forest
foundation in support of a program for
those mom and pop owners as someone um
called them so this is a program for
small Forest owners of 30 acres and up
um and it's a 20year program and it's
really focused on
helping those small land owners do
better Forest management
practices um so I want wanted to just
share that information with you I I do
have hot links in my letter so I will
email it to you so that you can take a
look at that program um last year there
have been a few references to the fact
that there was legislation last year
there were three bills um that sought to
restrict control or tax um car Forest
carbon programs and one bill survived
and as has been mentioned that has
created a public registry that's
available on the dncr website um I think
there are seven properties as of last
month that were
enrolled um that legislation that was
House Bill 1697 of last year that also
required the Department of Revenue
Administration to conduct two studies on
the tax impacts of um properties being
enrolled in programs they issued their
first report in
November um but said basically you not
it's a nice um overview of the issues
but they said probably not not enough
time has gone by for them to assess the
impact between you know when the
registry was created and when the bill
passed they do have another report due
under that bill um on November 1 of this
year which might provide more
information about the impact um so we
would urge you that if you do want to
move forward to maybe um hold on to this
bill uh look at that Dr report um as
several folks have already testified
this is a brand new issue there's a lot
to learn about it um and it might make
sense to pause and and take a look at
what the state might do to address um
the
impacts
um as I said I I will provide additional
uh information once I take a look at the
um the amendment if it changes our view
thank you thank you for your testimony
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes attorney n
Grace followed by Mr Charles
LC thank you madam chair n Grace for the
business and industry Association the
Statewide Chamber of Commerce um I'm
here really on the amendment uh
97h um just briefly the Bia uh opposes
new taxes on businesses we would
consider this amendment to be imposing a
new tax on businesses because there's no
existing tax on carbon credits there is
an existing um tax on stumpage um there
is a that's under uh 79 colon 3 there's
a standing Timber tax under 79 colon 5
and that's what the initial bill
proposed to amend um but what this would
do uh this amendment specifically would
do is add this new uh carbon credit tax
and one thing I would like to point out
to the committee is on page two of the
amendment lines 7-10 that's section uh
Roman 8 um it says that uh all other
provisions of RSA 79 are applicable to
the owner of the property so presumably
that owner is still subject to
importantly the standing Timber tax uh
which is what uh has been claimed as
being replaced here um but that
Amendment does not amend um that section
of the law as far as I am aware uh the
other point that I want to make is that
um these carbon contracts are very
complicated I attempted to understand
how exactly they work over the past
couple days and I am not that smart I
guess um because it really depends on
exactly how these are set up and there's
kind of there's a pretty wide variety of
options here
um you know you have ones that go from a
straight contract where you have you
know somebody come out assess the force
say 's this much you know Carbon credit
you'll get and there's a payment out
that year there are ones that have
periodic assessments attached to it so
after a period of time is there growth
or is there some sort of detriment like
there was an insect infestation or or a
forest fire or timbering that occurred
uh and there's different calculations
for how to account for those um there
are other ones that you see a payout uh
after the assessment over a period of
years subject to some
uh some differing
calculations um so in terms of exactly
how this um this uh it's not as straight
as basically you're going to make a
certain amount of profit and we're going
to take 10% of that because there's a
lot that's going to um be controlled by
the exact wording of of these contracts
and how that functions I'm certainly
happy to take any questions but that's
just something I wanted to flag for the
committee's consideration
thank you for your testimony are there
any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you for your
time next the chair recognizes Mr
Charles L followed by Mr Jason
stock welcome to Municipal and County
government good afternoon thank you
madam chair members of the committee uh
I'm Charlie LC am a license Forester New
Hampshire and have a consulting company
Innovative natural resource Solutions a
30-year-old company
um I've been Associated uh with uh
carbon and Forest carbon and Forest
carbon offset markets for many years so
i' probably considered at least somewhat
of an expert uh on the topic and I
certainly can answer uh questions that
you might have uh on that uh I'm here in
support of this legislation and the
amendment and the reason is that I
frankly have not found a different way
to deal with the issue before us which
is the loss of Timber tax revenue as a
result of the sale of forest carbon
offset credits if there was another
solution I'd be advocating for but I
think we've got to go down this path if
you are concerned as I am that um loss
of Revenue that otherwise would be going
to towns and cities from Timber tax uh
is going to occur as Forest carbon sales
uh happen so um with with that uh I
simply want to uh say that this whole
issue comes about as other speakers have
said as a result of what's happened on
the Connecticut Lakes Headwaters
property uh that is in Coos County uh
I'm a member of the legislatively um
derived uh committee citizens committee
to the Connecticut lak and so I'm in
imately uh familiar with what's gone on
up there and the loss of harvesting
that's occurred um lastly uh I want to
say that if you pass this legislation I
hope you do um there is a real need to
add an explicit requirement that
Department of Revenue Administration
develop administrative rules to
implement this because this cannot be
implemented with just the statute the uh
Dr has uh authority to draft
administrative rules for this section of
the statute but if if they choose to
delay um on this or not do it at all
which they occasionally do because
they're so busy and that goes for All
State agencies this won't get
implemented so i' i' encourage you to
add that to the bill to require them to
Devi to to devise uh administrative
rules um and lastly has been talk about
carbon program and so you may have uh
heard because a few speakers have talked
uh about different prrams so there are
many different Forest carbon offset
programs there's not just one um and
they actually cover different time
frames the most common one uh is not
associated with the California law on
the California air resources board and
it is the general uh uh Market that
occurs called the voluntary market and
that market is essentially
non-governmental it's worldwide and it's
really any entity that chooses to uh
offset their greenhouse gas emissions by
purchasing carbon offsets and carbon
offsets is the broad category Forest
carbon offsets are a subset of that
because there're other carbon offset
credits that get generated that are not
from forest although Forest are the
dominant ones and so the voluntary
Market is generally a 40-year market the
one that the Connecticut Lakes property
is in is the California Market which is
called the compliance market and it's
the only governmental related program
that's available in the Northeast uh in
the US that is a 100-year market um the
market that uh Miss Hatfield uh
described uh which is the family forest
carbon program for family forest owners
is 20 years but it's really in the
40-year market because they aggregate
many small land owners together and sell
them uh for that 40-year uh duration so
there's really the 40-year voluntary
market and the 100-year compliance
Market which is California and I'll end
there and I'd be glad to answer any
questions uh on uh on carbon
sequestration markets and so forth and I
did last year do a PowerPoint
presentation for another uh house
committee I'd be glad to do that for you
if you chose to to become more schooled
in this topic it's very complicated
thank you very much thank you Mr LC
questions for the
speaker representative grund thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question
so my question before and maybe you're
the perfect person to answer this so the
let's say the smaller land owner sells
or enters into a carbon contract so
they're going to get income I'm assuming
from a company who wants to purchase the
carbon credits from them right usually
through an intermediary they don't they
don't contract directly with that
company and that's where the the
programs come into play so the small B
but the small land owner will end up
with income on selling those credit
yes and no the family forest carbon
program that Miss Hatfield described uh
Works differently okay it actually pays
you to do certain Forest practices or
not do certain things like not cut
timber okay and it ends up owning your
carbon but it PID you pays you a flat
fee that's why I say there are many
programs out there that's the only one
that does it like that so generally I
think what you're suggesting is true but
in the case of that program for small
land owners it's not exact actly they're
not exactly getting paid for their
carbon sales okay yeah because I was
trying to understand if they're going to
end up with income and they're going to
pay tax on that income but then each
year they're going to pay 10% tax but
that occurs now for Timber so understand
saying they're going to get double taxed
because they've got income coming in but
they're also going to get hit with a 10%
tax that's what I'm trying to understand
right it's a good question thanks for
the question um So currently when you
harvest Timber and there are creative
ways and there are actual Federal St
statutes around timber in taxation and
if you have a good accountant they'll
know how to deal with it but the reality
is you are paying uh on that income from
Timber already so this is no different
from that this is not a new tax as I've
heard people describe it's really an
alternative tax to address the same
issue if you choose not to harvest
Timber but in the case of Timber you pay
an income tax at the federal level and
then you still pay the yield tax uh in
New Hampshire and that Revenue goes of
course to municipalities not to the
state so this is no different from that
if you sell carbon you again you got to
declare the income but you you you
theoretically need to pay on that income
on the federal level and then this would
do just as a Timber yield tax does and
charge uh in lie of essentially uh the
timber tax at the local level so that's
why I don't think it's a new tax it's
just a
rebranding further questions
have a quick one um with regards to the
CSP registry I I heard
um it referenced that there we there are
10 registrants right now seven I just
looked it up and and Patrick Hackley the
director of uh of division of force and
lands is here and his agency is the one
that created that as a result of Statute
but there are seven right now and I
think there's just over 180,000 acres in
the registry so far he and I were
speaking earlier and these small land
owners that we've been talking about
most of this is and the Seven that are
in the registry are only the large land
owns we're talking thousands of acres
and up and up meaning the Connecticut
Lakes property which is 100 well they
have 141,000 Acres uh entered into it
and so seven are in there now none of
the small family Forester owners are in
it yet okay so my my question
irrespective of the number was do we do
we know what type of uh I guess you
referred to it as a 100-year or 4 year
Market do we know what type of carbon
sequestration programs those acres are
under we do the registry does does
require that right director heckley yes
thank you it's in
there further questions seeing none
thank you thank
you at this time the chair recognizes Mr
Jason stock followed by Mr Brody Dees
welcome to Municipal and County
Government
nice wide chair thank you well good
afternoon uh for the record I'm Jason
stock I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association oh I do have WR some written
to so coming around is a
a discussion or position paper the the
New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association developed on the
subject of forest
carbon as an association we have members
all over the place on this one we have
land owners that say wow if someone's
going to pay me not to harvest Timber
what's wrong with that I it's a property
right that carpon a property right if
someone wants to pay me for that that
right what's wrong with that I also have
members or nhtoa also has members of
Sawmills and wood consuming companies
that say well wait a minute if you're
getting paid not to cut wood then how is
that going to affect my ability to
operate my
Sawmill my my paper mill my logging
business so we have we have members on
all over the place on this we spent a
lot of time developing a position paper
to try imbalance land owners rights with
some of these what I'll call Rural
economic
issues and and so what you have is is
the product of that I will say that is
always a like any other document it is a
work in progress but that is coming
around and what I would like to say is
carbon this is a carbon these carbon
programs are a new animal a new animal
for us we're trying to there's new
territory for us we had a committee
meeting policy committee meeting last
week and the comment was made that 20
years ago this wasn't even on the radar
who would have thought someone would pay
me not to harvest Timber um there's also
questions about is this a property is
this real real property you're kind of
placing a covenant on the property or
you're agreeing to do something in
exchange for for revenue is this is this
real property is this some type of a
real estate transaction it's a property
right um is there how does that apply um
as we all know there's a a real estate
transfer tax there's other taxes related
to real estate how does that apply the
one thing that in in Mr L and some of
the prior speakers touched on is these
this is a new issue this is a these are
new programs and we're plowing ground
that's never been plowed before many of
these agreements do not even get
recorded at the registry of deeds in
fact one of the recommendations we have
as an association is that for the sake
of transparency that we would recommend
that folks register this at the registry
of deeds so that say subsequent owners
but that's not always the case and for
good reasons sometimes the transactions
between an individual I may own a 100
acres or or 10 let's say 10,000 acres
and I may do a carbon deal on that on 10
10,000 acres worth of Timberland it may
not be tied specifically to a a
particular lot so this is you know there
there's a lot of questions and a lot of
a lot of pieces that we're looking at
trying to Fig get our head around is we
look at this as Timberland owners and
also as a as a forest products Forest
products
industry um we do recognize that if
there's a reduction in Timber harvesting
as we've seen in in Conn on the
Connecticut Lakes property there's no
question you have data there there is
there is a subsequent impact on the
forest products industry um we we do
recognize that and for us the the two
biggest issues that we're wrestling with
is is that impact which really kind of
comes down to a fundamental property
right whether I decide not to cut my
wood because I'm in a carbon program or
just because I want to grow big
trees who are we to say one's right one
isn't but the question about local
revenues and this question of local
Timber tax revenues is one that we've
and I've had a lot of conversations with
the sponsor of this bill we've met with
him and and some of his colleagues and
this is one that we do feel that there's
there's some Merit in in digging into
that having said all of that the the
um there were just too many questions
when we looked at that Amendment as an
association and as a committee and mind
you my policy committee and some of you
on this committee will appreciate this I
have five or six Selectmen there and
select women that are looking at this
saying all right how would I in my town
implement this you know so there was
some real kind of I'll say mechanical
questions that came into play that they
looked at but we do agree and we are
sympathetic to the to this issue um you
know an example is and you heard this
from from Mr LC these contracts vary
widely and it's not an annual it's not
an annual payment that's made I don't
sign up and then all of a sudden every
year there's an annual payment that's
made sometimes I'll say that the
payments are lumpy I may sign up a a a
piece of ground for a carbon program and
and they're purchasing the carbon that's
out there on my
landscape um I may get that payment in
installments over 5 years um then 10
years later they do a there's a uh
survey or a um crws done on that
property determine how much grew in that
10 years time and that 10 years growth
at that point I may I may enter that or
or I'll say submit that for payment or I
may cut it I may say guess what I've got
some beautiful red oak out there the
Market's good it's worth more for me to
cut that red oak than it is to sell it
to the carbon folks let's I'm going to
cut it I won't submit all of it or I
won't I'll only submit a portion of it
into the carbon program so again it's
you know looking at this trying to
figure out okay it's
not it's these can be lumpy it's
contract by contract the other piece is
when I cut it tree there's physical
evidence something was there there was a
taxable event as my friends at Dr would
say that tree was cut there's a stump
you can look at it you can calculate
with some degree of proximity how many
board feet how many cords or tons and
subsequently what species it is and then
subsequently what should you be paying
as far as a Timber tax on it these
carbon these are private transactions
most of them are not available for
public viewing and so you're trying to
you're trying to understand or trying to
tax something that you may not have all
on again I I guess what I I will I will
conclude with two points on that last
Point um you know the the last our last
comment on our our position paper is you
know make sure if we if we're going to
if we're going to pass legislation to do
something let let's make sure it's
enforcable and that it will accomplish
what we
want we would like to see these towns
remain whole there's no question we've
our committee agreed to that our board
everyone says yes we're not
sure House Bill 123 or the subsequent
Amendment we're not convinced that does
it we did commit and I've had
conversations with the with the sponsor
we were happy to work with him or any
other committee to try to hammer out a
process that does this we're not
convinced this is the process that does
this and we don't what we really don't
want to do is then pass this and then
tell Dr okay you guys figure it out
develop some rules and let's you know
develop some rules develop some forms
and develop some processes and then you
you figure it out because I think at
that point um again it's just another
varable
able and the last thing I and I heard
this comment is carbon is not
incompatible with forestry and Timber
harvesting there was a qu there's been
some question about is it an all or
nothing we have members that are in
carbon programs and for their management
it fits very well um I nhtoa has a
member it's a family ownership it's a
family ownership they've gone stem to
stern kind of weeding and thinning this
parcel they've hit a growth phase where
they're saying all right for the next 30
Years we're not going to harvest any
timber we've we've we've done the
weeding we have a nice stand of of trees
that are going to turn into beautiful
saw logs let them grow let them grow and
then the next 20 to you know 20 or 30
years from now we'll Harvest them and in
that instance that's a candidate they're
they're looking at a carbon program
saying all right in the interim here's
an opportunity to get to get paid for
that growth of that Timber the end of
that carbon program we can now move in
and start harvesting that harvesting
that Timber and so again there there is
an opportunity here to use these a
second example I'll leave with you and
this is more of a southern situation
where you had a sawmill that wanted a
certain diameter
log the landowner it was a it was a real
estate investment trust said well our
profarm phas tell us we can only grow
I'll pick a number 18 in you want 22 in
our profarma says our greatest rate of
returns at 18 in and they they said well
carbon markets why don't we enter these
these stands into a carbon Market we can
get paid to grow that additional 4 in
The Sawmill at the end of that carbon
program Sawmill gets the the timber the
quality that they want the real estate
investment trust their their proforma
Works they're happy and that's a
situation where it actually does work so
I I think it's these these programs
there as varied and as unique as Timber
and as the Timberland owners you have
Investment Trust you have families you
have
individuals and so again looking bring
to bring it all back to the bill we're
happy to work we're happy to work with
the sponsors or anyone else if there's a
subcommittee here or if if you hold the
bill we're happy to work on them to try
to accomplish what we believe is what
they want to do and that's figure out
that pole in that Municipal budget
that's caused by carbon right now we
don't know what it is as you heard um
from that Dr report and quite frankly
I'm not sure when I look at the bill and
I look at at 10% of a carbon contract
well what is that how does that compare
to veneer how does that compare to
pulpwood or biomass chips what are we
talking about that was the last piece
that my my committee said is what are
the dollars what are the dollars and
cents that we're looking at here we just
don't know with that I will conclude my
testimony I'm happy to try and answer
any questions and I thank you for your
thank you for your time this afternoon
questions seeing none thank
you so the last pink card that I have is
Mr bro
back thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you to the committee for letting
me speak today again my name is Brody
Dees I represent the nire municipal
Association and we are in support of the
bill as amended um
we do have a copy of the amendment and
first I do want to discuss the current
bill that you have in front of you um
RSA 79 colon 5 tar knowledge with
conversations I have with Dr and some of
our member municipalities has never been
utilized um it's not possible to really
utilize it because kind of the way the
statutes written you'll notice it says
um that a town or city is unreasonably
deprived of of Revenue because of the
failure of an owner to cut standing wood
or Timber when it shall have arrived to
the degree of maturity most suitable for
its use and then you can see you know
the amended language inserted in for
carbon sequestration but then the
existing statute says such standing W or
Timber shall be taxed in the same manner
as a general property which is
problematic of itself and subject to the
same rights of appeal and then Etc um
the Hampshire doesn't tax general
property anymore that went away a long
time ago um we tax real property so
there is that distinction there because
the statute it's very old um part of the
point was you know when we allowed the
timber tax to be levied in the state
which I believe was by constitutional
amendment in 1941 or
1942 um there were some communities that
were concerned that they would be
deprived revenues someone just chose to
stop cutting wood that they would like
revenues for literally the reason why
we're here today there are people who
are not cutting wood and it's depriving
municipalities of Revenue and it's you
know stagnating local economies in the
North Country um they kind of came came
up with this general tax credit where
the municipality would still tax them as
if they had cut the wood and they would
be able to keep track of that credit so
then if they did cut the wood in the
future they would say oh we're going to
credit this much towards your Timber tax
because now you've cut it well there's
issues with municipalities being able to
keep track of credits and how that would
be done it's not very explicitly stated
and it's also very hard to determine
what is unreasonably deprived
Revenue there's really no way to define
that and municipalities that have have
in the past said should we try to
utilize this their legal council has
said no CU you're just going to end up
in court trying to determine what is
unreasonably deprived of Revenue and um
and what is technically you know quote
degree of maturity most suitable for use
because different land owners have
different reasons why they're cutting
the wood at different points of the
trees's maturity and Municipal officials
would probably also have their own kind
of way of determining that so trying to
amend RSA 79 colon 5 to utilize you know
to try to capture this loss revenue for
carbon tax credits it's not workable and
we really appreciate representative
Davis bringing forward an amendment to
tax carbon sequestration the same way
that that Timber would be taxed if it
was cut all that's trying to happen is
these especially disproportionately
rural North Country communities or even
some communities in Carol County you'll
see if you look at the registry there's
a lot of land in the town of Osby for
example that's being used for carbon
sequestration we're trying to make sure
they aren't deprived Revenue and trying
to think of a fair in way to make sure
these revenues can be raised and our
opinion is 79 colon 3-c proposing the
amendment is a fairway it kind of sets
up the tax in the way that the existing
Timber Tax Works it has an objective um
looking at the tonnage of carbon that's
for the capture I also want to go on the
record and say that while the Bia and
some of the business organizations have
said that we have this existing 79 colon
5 which has never been used and we
wouldn't recommend anyone try to use it
we would be okay with repealing 79 colon
5 in conjunction with adopting this
amendment for the proposed 79 3-c that
representative Davis um has proposed so
then there isn't any concern of double
taxation um doing both in conjunction we
think would help quell some of the
concerns of the quote double Taxation
and also help municipalities especially
those in the North Country who are being
deprived these revenues because of very
complicated tax schemes that are being
cooked up in other states to incentivize
a car credit industry um which is
currently right now having a negative
impact on the overall Timber industry
and the revenues that municipalities are
used to depending upon to help keep
their property tax rates low and uh need
to you know have to dip less into the
pockets of property taxpayers and with
that I'll answer any questions thank you
Mr Dees questions for the speaker seeing
you so that is the last card that I have
for this bill so I will ask is there
anybody present who wishes to speak to
this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do
so seeing none the chair recognizes
representative Gilman to report out the
blue
sheets thank you madam chair on the
remote signin there were five in support
and 16 opposed uh but I will say 16 and
five are in play because a couple of the
the texts do not are not associated with
this
against thank you and with that I will
so I apologize um representative om we
we are about an hour behind
schedule so once the clerk is organized
for this public hearing we'll
begin thank you mam chair I well we'll
just
hold at this time the chair will open
the public hearing on House Bill
247 authorizing municipalities to hold a
referendum on whether to allow historic
horse
racing so at this time the chair will
recognize representative M welcome to
Municipal and County government and good
afternoon thank you madam chair a
pleasure to be here uh for the record my
name is representative Bill M Hillsboro
10 city of
Nashua I'm here to present the bill to
allow a referendum on historic horse
racing in cities and towns this is a
local issue Bill uh do you or do you
want to have a vote on whether to allow
casinos to develop in your local cities
and
towns so the background of this is uh
about 3 four years ago there was a bill
passed to allow historic horse racing
and these are basically slot machines
that uh are very attractive to play and
the terms and conditions for these slot
machines were quite attractive to The
Operators
for example if you wanted to open a
casino in
Massachusetts you'd be paying between 25
and $85 million for a license to operate
a property with a th000 slot
machines if you want to operate a
property with a th000 slot machines in
New
Hampshire your license fee is
$250 so we've offered quite attractive
conditions to uh expand Casino gaming uh
in New Hampshire
in the past when we've looked at
expanding gaming we've had a casino bill
that looked at
various uh impact on cities and towns
such as do we want to have a referendum
to opt in uh what terms do we want to
have for mitigation to the cities and
towns uh do we have want to have an opt
out
provision um how should the money go
well much of that's not been really
thought out with the bill that allowed
historic racing in New Hampshire so the
current situation we have and speak to
my city of Nashua is that we had a mom
and pop uh chable gaming establishment
lucky moose is one
example uh Bar and Grill uh some C
tables and uh now they were allowed to
expand it to Historic horse
racing so what happens is that the
business now gets sold to an out ofate
operator uh in this case ecl
entertainment
and they uh buy the vacant property in
our Prime retail District the Sears
store right at the
border and now they're in the process of
opening up
a major Casino two floors 180,000 square
feet over 100 over a thousand slot
machines and I talked to my folks here
in asille and they said well you know
this is coming and they said
what uh well how did this happen I said
well we passed a bill that allowed the
equivalent of slot machines and we did
not put any optin on this situation so
it's allowed and the opportunity was
taken by the business people and now the
sear store is going to be a major casino
right on our
border
okay so one of the objections I had was
my prior experience in Ways and Means
which is whenever we would expand
gambling we always had an optin
provision I worked on the casino on The
Kino bill which I've passed out a copy
of for your reference and said well you
can have Kino we the state will allow it
but if you want Kino then you should opt
in for it and NASA passed on the first
Go Round And opted in on second go round
some cities have most cities and towns
have but we wanted to give local control
to expanded gambling well we had a
loophole in this
uh historic horse racing law that did
not have this
optin so uh my bill is to ask the
question of should we now have an optin
for any future historic horse racing
establishments uh right now there's 14
charal gaming establishments that are
allowed to have historic racing
licenses and our recent experience is
that these won't just stay as as who
they they are they'll be sold out most
likely to a large operator who build a
major
Casino which is allowed in your city or
town you don't have that provision to
say we don't want
it so I propose that we should have that
Authority that the people in the cities
and towns should be able to say yes or
no if we want to have a major
Casino uh evolve from the small historic
gaming property that we've had
so the bill takes the language of The
Kino Bill and adds a couple of
paragraphs which basically grandfathers
the properties that already have the
historic horse racing
machines until such time as the year
ends then anything after January 1st of
2026 any additional properties that want
to have historic racing in your city and
town will have to go through the ref
process and with that I'll take
questions seeing none thank you thank
King
okay does the committee have any
okay
oh okay so I will now recognize Ms
Alicia
Preston good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County
government good afternoon thank you
madam chair and members of the committee
my name is Alicia Preston I represent
the New Hampshire charitable gaming
operators Association we just have one
slight concern with this bill and that's
the eligibility point that represented M
uh pointed out which is January 1st
2026 right now while there are 14
licenses there are five who appli to the
Lottery Commission current law states
that those are that's the max that's a
topout that anybody can have store
course racing in New Hampshire until
January of 2031 that's current law and
we just want to make sure those five
those of whom get approved are protected
in this bill as they've already done
enormous amount of investment and
process in the state so if there could
just be a language tweak that says um
entities licensed or
eligible to param Mutual wages on storic
concern
questions could could you repeat what
you just said I was taking notes sure um
on page one line 29 it says
notwithstanding the provisions of this
section entities licensed to sell if it
said licensed or eligible to
sell I think that would solve that and
again on page two
line7 provided that licenses eligible by
valid you said page two line s yes like
then you said provided that licenses
eligible prior to J jary 1 2026 shall
remain
valid and again those are the only ones
that can operate already in the state
until
2031 thank
you further
you so that did represent my last pink
card is there anyone else present who
wishes to speak to this bill who has not
yet had the opportunity to do so
seeing none the chair will recognize
representative Gilman to report out the
blue sheets thank you madam chair the
remote sign in shows two in support and
four
opposed and the paper blue sheet is on
its
it paper blue sheet is one in favor
thank you representative Gilman and with
that the public hearing on House Bill
closed so with that that concludes our
publicly notice business for today and I
think what we will do is take a a small
break and we will um gather back in Jim
I need a couple
yeah in 10 minutes at which time we will
you
e
good afternoon Municipal and County
government will now move into an
executive session and the chair would
like to welcome representative Howland
at this time I will open the executive
session on House Bill 92 prohibiting an
individual from SIM simultaneously
serving on the local Zone board and
planning
board i' like make motion yep the chair
would like to recognize representative
2025-the Elwood would you like to speak
to your amendment I would thank you
thank you um the law currently provides
for one member of a zba or a planning
board to sit on both
boards
um and this amendment is to avoid
conflict of interest issues and
unnecessary costly
appeals um it provides or mandates that
members serving on both boards recuse
the themselves from voting on matters
previously decided in a quasi judicial
capacity
by the board in which they voted as a as
a member um so if you're sitting on the
planning board and a zoning
board you cannot
um uh vote on matters previously decided
by the zoning
board so this has bipartisan support
with um Representatives power and frock
providing valuable input as
co-sponsors thank you representative
amendment seeing none the motion before
225-3100 to House Bill 92 if you are in
favor of accepting the amendment you
will vote Yes if you are opposed to the
amendment you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes
representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes
okay representative
Howland yes
representative
Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative
Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes chairman power
yes
18 Amendment
d317 H to House Bill
zero the chair recognizes representative
Elward for a subsequent motion I move a
to pass with amendment is there a second
you was it representative Murphy that
you representative Ella would would you
motion don't need to no no thank you
okay so seeing none the motion before us
is ought to pass with Amendment if you
are in favor of the motion then you will
vote Yes if you are opposed to the
motion then you will vote no the clerk
will call the
RO Vice chair McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative word
yes the clerk votes
yes representative frons
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative Howland
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majority
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grundt
the motion passes with a vote of 18 to
zero therefore the committee recom
recommendation on House Bill 92 is ought
to pass with Amendment without objection
the recommendation will go on to the
house
calendar and representative Elwood will
you yeah I thought I said that well was
that I thought I said that um the vice
chairman was just confirming that that
would be on the consent calendar the
answer is
yes
okay and with that I will close the
next I will open the
executive session on House Bill
272 exempting certain agricultural
regulations um the chair recognizes
representative Colby for a
motion thank you chair uh I hope I do
this right I'd like to make a motion of
odd to pass on HB 272 thank you is there
a second I'll second it representative
Kosinski seconds that motion
representative Colby would you like to
uh
no so the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill
272 if you are in favor of the motion
you'll vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion motion you will vote no the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
France representative inski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative Howland
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative
frock
yes representative Colby yes
representative gerana
yes representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommendation on
House Bill 272 is ought to pass without
objection the recommendation will go on
calendar and the report will be written
at this time I will open the executive
session on House Bill 149 FN relative to
Warrant article approvals at ballot
sorry I will I will enjoy his motion if
it's the same one I want to
[Laughter]
make okay does it start with an i and
end with an L
probably the chair recognizes
representative Murphy for a motion
Madame chair I like to make a motion for
itl is there a second I'll second it
thank you
um representative Murphy would you like
to speak to your motion sure um this one
would make it make it extremely
difficult to uh pass any sort of uh
money money articles and an attempt to
itl is there any
so I I would like to um say that I will
be voting against the motion of
itl this bill is I I do not see this as
rank Choice voting I see this bill as um
a bill legislation that is very much
needed I'm happy for those
um
citizens who are in um towns or school
districts
that don't have problems with regards to
Warrant articles being amended but
unfortunately in the town that I reside
in I am involved in three annual
meetings and I personally have seen um
the need for this
legislation Time and Time and Time Again
additionally as um having been a State
Rep now for my third term I do um
network with other state reps and I also
hear from them uh similar stories of
Warrant articles um being amended in
such a way to uh defeat the bill and um
to to to defeat the warrant
article and like I said it it is it's a
um it's it's a it's a persistent problem
that we see across the state and I would
like to share that I I recently got uh
an email from estate rep who um shared
with me that at their annual
deliberative session in their town they
citizens had put a petitioned warant
article
up to elect members of the Conservation
Commission and that bill um was signed
into law just last year 2024 was house
bill
1302 and yep the the petition waren
article was was at at the deliberative
session to clearly elect members to the
Conservation Commission because prior
that the only option was that the
Conservation Commission members would be
appointed and the deliberative session
in an attempt to just squash this
petition Warr article and not really
enable it to have a a vote they changed
the language to um keep the commission
as
appointed and I would note that in the
bill that was signed in into law that
the election of members to the
Conservation Commission there it is
statutory language so um for the
moderator in that particular
municipality that should not have been
allowed but it was because there's um
um policing or enforcement what have you
so I just share that
um as a most recent and it happened just
last week um data point to to
demonstrate the the need for for this
bill and I have I could go on and on but
I won't so for for those reasons I will
be voting against the itl motion
discussion seeing none and the motion
before us is in expedient to legislate
on House Bill 149 FN if you are in favor
of the motion you will vote Yes if you
are opposed to the motion you will vote
role Vice chair
McDonald yes on the
itl representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative
Howland
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerna
yes representative Gerard yes
no the motion passes with a vote of 16-2
the committee recommendation on House
legislate is there any objection to it
going onto the consent
calendar I have an I have an objection
calendar so the committee
Gilman I suppose I will be writing The
Minority
Report and with that I will close the
339 at this time I will open the
executive session on House Bill 339
plans the chair recognizes
representative frock for a motion Madame
chair I move itl on HB 339 thank you is
there a second I'll second that
representative uh chairman MC Vice
representative frock would you like to
speak to your motion yes I would thank
you madam chair um I'm voting itl on HB
339 which adds proposes to add two new
subparagraphs and two new chapters to
the master plan of towns and cities in
New Hampshire uh the reason that I
proposed itl are many but I will give
you two of them um first there was no
sponsor that appeared before this
committee to introduce the bill or
answer any questions secondly in my
position as planning board chair and
master planning task force chair in the
town of Enfield we have just completed
uh probably five years of work on our
master plan
and adding these two chapters is
entirely
unnecessary uh the first suggested
chapter has to do with Agriculture and
food
production those have been covered or
could be covered in any one of a number
of places such as the land use
chapter
um resources Economic Development it it
could go almost anywhere the second
suggested chapter is a catchall that
says add anything else and that's just
kind of
unnecessary the hour is late I won't
comments seeing none the motion before
us is is inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 339 relative to Municipal
Master
plans if you are in favor of the motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Alward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative
Howland
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori yes
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
the motion passes with a vote of 17 to1
the committee recommendation on House
Bill 339 is in expedient to legislate
without objection the recommendation
calendar thank you and the report will
frock and with that I will close the
executive session on House Bill
next I will open the executive session
on House Bill 407 setting a minimum
threshold for the adoption of town and
school budget and spending items for
towns using a ballot to select such
meeting um
at this time the chair recognizes
representative Dolan for a motion mam
chair i' like to make a motion to itl
407 is there a second second
representative Murphy seconds that
representative Dolan would you like to
speak to your motion yes this uh bill
has a couple of rather vague uh elements
to it one is to uh that the that the uh
me any measure at the town meeting has
to to have at least 15% of registered
voters and also a majority of those
voting um it's unclear when 15 when do
you strike the line for 15% of the
voters some towns do it the the day
prior to town meeting others do it at
town meeting and majority of those same
thing the majority of those voting uh
it's it's that's a vague uh and it
appears to be left up to the town
moderator or some another uh individual
to determine that so in in light of that
it needs to be it until the the bill is
better
written thank you is there any
discussion on this motion representative
grund thank you madam chair um so I just
want to add that I I think the reason I
do support the itl it's uh not just the
vagueness of the 15% but I do struggle
with the 15% because forcing people to
show up is one thing but we can't you
know like how do you force people to
show up I mean the people who do show up
do so by
choice and for the people who don't show
up which would might be a majority
you're now putting their will on the
people who do show up so now you've
suppressed their voice so I really do
struggle with the
discussion seeing none then the motion
before us is an expedient to legislate
on House Bill
407 if you are in favor of the motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes
the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative
Walker
yes representative Howland
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori yes
representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to0 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 407 is inexpedient to
legislate without objection the
recommendation will go on to the house
consent
calendar thank
you with that oh I forgot so who would
report what oh representative Dolan
and with that I will close the executive
next I will open the executive session
on House Bill
447 relative to property tax exemptions
veterans the chair recognizes
representative Murphy for a
motion thank you madam chair I'd like to
make a motion for
itl is there a
who pick
jerard um representative Murphy would
motion this just seems to be uh almost
like you'd be giving money way back to
the veterans if it goes over the amounts
of the property tax therefore um it's
really
unworkable is there any further comments
or
discussion representative Gerard thank
you madam chair basically again I
understand what the representative said
but I think our bigger concerns is the
fact that the VA housing standards are
much stricter than the Ada guidelines um
and no one can clearly Define what makes
a house ADA Compliant as well so those
are the reason why I agree with the
itl further comments or
discussion so I I have some
comments so um we understand that the
bill proposes to expand eligibility
Criterion for RSA 72
236a which is certain disabled veterans
to exempt the full property um taxes um
on their
Homestead so um for those of you who
were here last year on this committee
and for as a reminder or a refresher and
for those who were not on this
committee we had a bill 2024 House Bill
1154 that came before the committee and
I happen to have been the prime sponsor
of that bill so that was that bill was
filed at the joint request of the Deputy
adant general of the New Hampshire
National Guard as and the director of
the New Hampshire Department of military
Affairs and veteran services so they
reached out to me and they
um asked that this bill be filed for um
this particular property tax exemption
be because they had found that in its um
application was extremely um
confusing and what was happening is that
in the mun
municipalities the either the assessors
or the select board uh
Selectmen they were confused as to you
know what was the eligibility Criterion
and and additionally there were veterans
that were um coming before these these
parties and and they were saying well
well they were believing that they were
eligible for this property tax exe
exemption and also the um New Hampshire
Department of military Affairs and
veteran
services as well as the VA in New
Hampshire they were getting inquiries
and you know people are very confused
and people were upset and perhaps
rightly so and so the issue at hand is
that this particular certain disabled
veterans property tax exemption was
being applied um differently across the
state and and that's a
um what was what was asked and what was
done is that the language was was made
more
clear um to uh State very very clearly
and I I won't go through all the details
but um it it
it
clarified that this tax exemption was um
linked to the sah and sha
grants the other thing um that I would
note is that this bill here before us
would essentially
undo that legislation that was signed
into law because it it goes in and it
expands um the
eligibility with its Language by um
including a veteran who and it's it
talks about it adds on to the sah or SHA
home um eligibility criteria and then it
adds or owns a home that is ADA
Compliant and meets the needs of their
disability which I would um concur with
representative Gerard that that's very
confused that's that's just so broad
it's open and and furthermore there's no
real way to establish you know what that
is and what's the documentation so
therefore to insert have this um amended
into this current statute is just going
back 10 steps and and also there's the
second um addition or is modified
through the VA hospital system well to
be clear those were the issues that was
also causing confusion because veterans
you know would like for example um you
know if I heard a story where a a
veteran had received money to install a
walk-in um tub bathtub
disability but the problem what with
regards to the legislation last year
that that's not what the criteria is and
it's just it's
like I said we we would be going
backwards um with this
bill um and the last thing that that I
will say is that um to be clear
currently in in New Hampshire statutes
we have seven a total of seven veterans
tax credit credits and exemptions so we
have the standard as well as the
optional veterans tax credit and that's
the standard is $50
and the optional ranges from $51 to
$750 and I understand that there's a
Senate bill that that we may see that
seeks to increase that upper Max to
1,000 we have the all veterans tax
credit um which is available we have the
optional tax credit for combat service
that's for service members having combat
service we have the surviving spouses we
also have the veterans of Allied Forces
for veterans of foreign military service
we have tax credit for service connected
total disability which is pnt at 4,000
um and we recently passed a bill in the
house um where we raised that to
$5,000 and that was House Bill 99 and
then lastly we have this um certain
disabled
veterans so um I feel that we we do take
care of our veterans and um the final
final comment would be that with any
type of a tax exemption or credit and
this one certain disabled veterans this
is 100% of the property
taxes when we
um have that when a municipality um well
for this it's it if a veteran qualifies
they get it what my point what I'm
getting at is that it shift is shifts
the tax burden to the other taxpayers
within the municipality
you further
comments seeing none the motion before
us is inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill 447
if you are in favor of the motion then
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion then you will vote no the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France yes
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative Howland
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby yes
representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero the committee recommendation on
House Bill 447 is inexpedient to
legislate without objection the
recommendation will go on to the house
consent
report and with that I will close the
447 so that um wraps up our our publicly
noticed business for today and I have
some afternoon
announcements so first there is a house
session scheduled for this Thursday
February 13th at 10:00 a.m. after
initial House business the house will
meet in a joint convention with the
senate for governor aot's budget address
after the H after that the house will
have a regular session for the purpose
of acting on house bills as a reminder
please hold Thursday February February
TW um I'm not sure if it's going to be
February wait 20th oh sorry this is
about a house session I should just read
my notes as a reminder please hold
Thursday February 20th open for a
possible future house session then for
the week of February 16th please hold
February 18th open for hearings and
executive session and then for that last
week in February that would be the week
of February
23rd please hold um most likely
Wednesday February 26th open for
hearings
only okay is there any
questions okay and I think um at the
beginning here I we did pass around that
committee contact
list yes okay very good so um the chair
will call all the meeting now
adjourned thank you and have a great